[Music]
good afternoon everybody
it's Wednesday cheers my dude it is
Wednesday my dudes
and also man it is Wednesday
October 4th
as we rush towards the uh God's holiday
of Halloween there's no more important
day
uh in the whole year
I'm telling you and it's one mischievous
day man
it's the devil's this song's got me
tiptoeing through a floor of calc trumps
today's episode is sponsored by
expressvpn thank you
thank you so
um
so tomorrow's leftovers Friday we're
having our big members drive and we've
we've nailed down some of the I think
we've nailed it down more or less it's
gonna be so much fun you guys
and we're gonna have an element where
more
for every member we extend the time yes
and for that reason we'll be starting at
11 P.M
am 11 A.M Pacific time
11 A.M on Friday
so that we don't go so freaking long
good morning
um but we were talking I don't I don't
know because I I don't think it's gonna
go crazy long I think maybe six hours
see we'll see I hope not
I'll be here all night I know you
well I was gonna say that nobody has to
like stay Beyond what's so reasonable
like and then because I could probably
stay you know I can make a call
I told I gave I gave you the heads up
you stay all night yeah I could I could
if I had to but oh boy I'm saying I
could if I had to yo you're gonna be
held to that now
I don't think it's gonna happen though
right it's the biggest trick in the year
well I don't think we have enough uh
incentives planned to go all night so it
would devolve into just a very casual
thing right at a certain point
um but we do have some things planned
most of which just boil down to
yeah so you want to read some of the
ones we have written down uh Ian has the
list you got it ready you wanna give us
a breakdown welcome to 2023 membership
Drive extreme podcast I know what the
one that I'm the most excited about is
Ethan has committed to allowing me
to shave his head absolutely I said yeah
dude people don't think people think
it's a big deal I I don't go for it man
for the people I'll do it I can even
shave my eyebrows off as another one I I
had a few thoughts of uh
the approach I was gonna take really how
well what kind of approach are we
thinking not with fire well we can do it
no no fire no fire involved that would
never
um
there can be stages there can be stages
to shaming it down like you'll wind up
completely shaved
yeah it's a story yeah okay we're here
I'm a Storyteller myself
I'm looking at the tattoo in the
previewer it looks pretty good
it's sick dude you look so
badass man
the fact it didn't even work a really
hard place to get attacked that's what I
hear skin is super sensitive and you
don't realize looking at it but you see
this is the most this is the one of the
most painful Parts in the whole body
right under the crease
you know you and that puppy look tough
he's tough he's definitely a tougher
he's a tough one badass yes sick
it's sick dude
um yeah you can you want to shave my
eyebrows off I'm cool with all that uh
it's not up to me it's up to the people
well we can add that as a as a goal all
right
we can shave my beard my eyebrows and my
hair you think it's like for the people
I'll be like a little
don't say it
what do you think I was gonna say you're
gonna say like a hot little twink no I
was not that was definitely you said
that's weird enough being the one to say
it I was thinking like egg you're lying
that is exactly what you were gonna do
you said it bro I know because you asked
me what you were gonna say but I didn't
say that you said that just want to make
that the audience announce them right
jack it off
God damn this coffee is crazy love told
me that something shocked me to my core
you guys have heard
raving about this coffee it is so sweet
and so creamy it's not even coffee it's
like hot cocoa right um it tastes like
one of those you know those like Werther
toffee things that your grandma keeps it
tastes like that but better
and they put some sleeping on top man I
didn't do that and then love tells me
what did you tell me this morning love
all right listen I don't like coffee
right so like I want to try this this is
such a love thing to do so I I brewed it
I brewed the coffee and the Machine this
yeah I take a sip
that still taste like coffee so I
go to the fridge look around like maybe
some milk and I see a big container of a
sweetener mmm I like my coffee I just
dumped that in there half
half maybe I don't know you should just
busting a coconut sweetener very good
yummy that's just I mean I wish you guys
could taste this this is like 10 creams
10 sugars
vodka I mean I just I love your palette
you really are
[Applause]
should we get Taco Bell for you today
love sure have you been eating Taco Bell
a lot
yeah what's your big go-to lately uh
three or are you playing that he's a
young man he's not gonna die he's a Taco
Bell
I thought he was playing the Death Note
for your diet
that's how my brain works bro it's a
really up Taco Bell Bell let it
happen bro come to the Bell that's the
sound it's gonna make it when you're on
the toilet you know it's true I never
that's not an issue for me never ever me
neither level
you don't eat meat and you have a
youthful disposition yeah I guess that's
it I don't eat the love the ground beef
yes can I talk about your pooping
happens he only poops like twice a week
it's three times a week three times well
yeah because he doesn't need fiber he
doesn't believe in it I don't believe it
that's what happens when you don't eat
any fiber do you eat any fiber I don't
know what fiber is it's like fruits
vegetables
potato fries no it's not really fibrous
it's more Carby popcorn popcorn yeah I
eat popcorn I don't think that has fiber
maybe it does maybe when I order it I
have been on a Ramen kick lately dude
and uh there's Shives in there but I I
removed chives those are like tiny
little flesh
I remember they put like you pick them
out they put like too much I have to
like take off that take over that so I
just get broth Ramen and chives you guys
yeah air popped popcorn is very high in
fiber the daily value in one bag nice
let's go dude how much does daily value
in one serving
in one ounce there's 3.6 grams see
that's a lot that's not a lot oh
I think there's five grounds in just one
of my Metamucil gummies that I take
three of hold on daily
requirement should eat at least 21 to 25
grams of fiber A Day Men oh that's women
and the men should eat 30 to 38 grams a
day which is more popcorn so you see
videos
you know oh it's so hard to be a woman
men are we're having to eat 38.
I don't get it just give me a way I can
eat that in one spoon I'll just like
just swallow it can I recommend
um get on some Metamucil Metamucil yeah
because pooping twice a week is not
three times three times that is three
times is less concerned that's within
the good uh limit yeah three is okay
you're supposed to do it every day but I
think there's a healthy variance to that
yeah three is fine yeah I do recommend
normal and healthy have bowel movements
anywhere between three times a week and
three times a day that's a big spread
three times a day is not right
I don't care what they say
anyone's pooping three times a day
that's a little concerning I poop five
times a day someone is it more that's
concerning three times a day Zach is
that what you're saying it's like
roughly two two to three two to three
two or three times a day I enjoy pooping
bro okay so are they are they must be
neat little tight little logs because if
you don't have much time for the food to
build up yeah it varies I have IBS so
probably part of what's the texture like
on those
um soft serve wow every day not like
every day like Carvel if you shout in a
cone would you be able to tell the
difference nah dude take a get a fudgy
the whale my dude stop
good job I love pooping I saw a video
maybe you guys saw this it was in China
there was a carnival ride
and it was like swinging back and forth
and people on the ground were watching
and
a bunch of got catapulted so much
Adam pulled it off oh you gotta give me
that I have it but can we we probably
can't show that it's just yeah I don't
think it's not really oh I found it I
found a big Reddit post but they uh
deleted it here it is
um I see it maybe you can call it out oh
there it is
I'm thinking I want to name her Babs
what do you think of that name for that
yeah Babs I was thinking about how that
feels right Ruth I think Marilyn like
Ruth no we were talking it has to be a
name that's like her name right she
can't say anything too intricate it's
bad her name is Lorraine if I'm not
mistaken oh that's a good one yeah
so for anyone wondering I weighed 166
pounds when I got to America maybe we
should make a we have a scale here I
haven't weighed myself
we used to have one in the bathroom we
didn't have a digital one here I think
so it might be a little bit off but yeah
digital or accurate No it's not pretty
bro it's not the reason it's like um I'm
saying it's analog let's take a look
let's get you on that scale I'm all good
with it so so you said when you got here
you were what 166 166.
or maybe slightly below yeah do you
think you've gained weight or have
remained steady oh you have probably
five pounds
more to hug
yeah we got weight we got weights in me
we got weight in love and do you blame
that just because you've been enjoying
the food here so much
yeah I also haven't been able to cook
and stuff so
would you if you could
yeah yeah you would I cook a lot I love
cooking really what kind of stuff do you
make uh you know I mean I don't pretend
it to be make super healthy food but at
least it's not like super like processed
whatever like hamburger type so I I
like to make pasta I like to make a uh
hamburgers like really yeah I make the
from mince meat and stuff like that look
at that I find that I tend to eat less
when I prepare my food at home too yes I
know if you find the same yeah no I
agree because the portions are nuts here
I don't know
when you go out here you get two meals
dude it's nuts yeah it's up with
this servio I'll eat it you'll eat it
all yeah of course so I used to go
through that phase two I would eat
everything on the plate and I just
there's a certain point in your life a
certain age
when you just gotta put the fork down
yeah or pay the price I feel you know
your way around some meat but I'm I'm uh
thank you Dan
I think I can loose this way pretty fast
I'm not gonna lie coping
so wait what have you been getting down
with lately Ramen a lot of ramen Ramen
instant noodle
I buy Ramen ramen's good but I don't
think what it's called Silver Lake Ramen
as a Boston not out I've been hitting
Taco Bell every now and then
ramen's good I don't think that's like
necessarily A really horrible no it's
not horrible yeah that's a 10. what did
we find back there Olivia
I think it was moved and I asked Teddy
fresh and they only have a scale for um
items not humans no like uh well that
well and so do you want me to see it
yeah we well it's like a drug
technically as a item that's true yeah
commodity that's right it's what is it
like a cow measure I mean like a hoof
wear I mean for like merchandise why
don't you guys why don't you go with
love or somebody and you can film it put
you on the scale yeah yeah we can do it
off the Record off the location a remote
can we can we um
I guess we'll have to have to film it we
can't do it live probably right then or
I don't know if our wireless system will
like going through I could possibly
Order Drive
let me see if like instacart delivers
human scales but are you saying that
their scale is too heavy duty it's too
lightweight right oh it's not heavy duty
enough right it's like a shirt it's for
like clothing yeah let's get it let's
order one okay
on it
there's people being triggered right now
I do not believe in Scales scales aren't
inherently fat shaming well I don't
really give a well wait I am I'm
just curious how much I literally weigh
it's not this is love's face I'm just
I'm just impersonating there's at least
one person in the audience who's a man
someone suggested we just weigh him
piecemeal like each limb and then add it
up that's you mind if we do that that's
fine yeah yeah let's get it can we get a
scale out here uh ASAP please or how
about we all pick them up and guess each
[Laughter]
you said you came at 166.
165 and then can I you have all your
clothes and shoes on is that okay
yeah I mean that probably adds a few
pounds all right so turn around
okay ready
oh bro you put on some weight I think
you think
[Music]
this is Hardcore man I mean
I'm up I'm gonna put this up I think
overall you're not gonna like what I'm
about to say
hit me with it hit me but we're gonna
find out I think you're at around 180.
no in a way maybe that's what I think
dude logging you at 180. you were a
brick bro I didn't expect you to be like
I am I've been telling people that I am
a little bit bigger than what I am no
I'm not calling you fat you're dense bro
you're like a brick house yeah yeah I
haven't pooped in two days too
five at least okay who else wants to
lift love I love them and I'm serious
this is stepping up babies stepping up
you want to just can I I'll give a more
precise I'll say one seven eight Justin
17 178 Yeah 178 178.
okay
all right oh look okay Amy's going for
the uh
the marriage way I was thinking out yeah
that's that's a good way to do it he
said not bad he said no what does that
mean baby that's good what are you
guessing yeah I guess around 160 165.
you think he lost weight what are you
talking about
I mean
I'm 170. so and you think he's lighter
you think he lost weight
all right
165.60 yeah you pick a number I'll go to
cam now
pick a precise number here Abby can I
give my 165. can I get my guess without
picking them up
sure why not uh I'm gonna say 181. oh
you're just dude that's you're
just doing the Jeopardy thing no Price
is Right but yeah our Price is Right I
mean I thought you said 178. I said 178.
Cam's got him cam
I don't think he's gained a pound that's
definitely 166 on or 165 on the spot
really oh so ab and cam are aligned I
say one same guess 176.
Olivia is saying okay thank you for not
over cutting me don't worry
well the undercut is pretty close too
Zach
you don't want to you don't want to lift
him
I'll lift I'm sure yeah let's get him in
the air get him in the air come here
baby look them up let's get those let's
get those feet off the ground baby
you know what I'm gonna change my answer
oh interesting go ahead I think he's
lost weight really I think he's 160. wow
damn
wow
I just want to be a wild card with it
sure sure one set 175 I'm changing it
175. so Zach's at 175. I'm at 178. yes
that's right so I still have the highest
guess you do you do did you guess again
let's get those feet off the ground you
should we should two people hold them
maybe will that
get over there
if that's sweet
and and can I ask you this love
oh go ahead Dan and then I'll ask you
Dan is crunching the numbers he's
thinking deeply and hardly between
number eight I'm gonna say 172 pounds
172. yeah I'm gonna guess 173.
that's 173 thanks a lot now love now
that everybody's lifted you let me ask
you this yeah whose arms do you feel the
safest in
um the best safest lift was a b because
it was slow yeah he liked any cradle and
he put me down slowly yeah I got you and
who do you think is the strongest is
that the same would that be ABS no I
think uh probably Sac Zach was he's a
Powerhouse yeah he I just shot I almost
shot up dude it's the tank he's the tank
I've never been that sixth the six four
I believe today
so I think higher six five right it goes
up uh it's like the uh members this is
like the member stream it goes up every
second so I don't move at all on my free
time right so I have this thing where if
I like go on a on a thing right I do I
have an active day I lose a lot of
weight very very fast in like one day
you're saying well not but like you we
went to we went uh some of us in the
crew and on like a holiday right to to a
lake uh and I lost weight during that
weekend just because I moved around a
lot we walked and hiked okay for sure so
I feel like I'm not that worried because
you could be you could shed it yeah yeah
yeah that's good I feel like every time
you take a you must lose five
pounds I lost like eight pound I can
lose eight pounder eight eight one oh
one I was like eight pounds brother yeah
you got fecal build up bro yeah and then
uh Ian I know do you want to lift him do
you want to participate in this I I
don't want to exclude you
I
I'm on a heating pad my back I did oh no
right yeah I was laying on the floor
earlier wait what happened to your back
I have no idea but it hurts you just
woke up weird
yeah yeah I'll let them in I'll lift him
uh in our personal time right you want
to take you want to take an unlifted
guess
I'll say 170. has anyone said 170 no
no I said 175. are you okay do you need
a do you need anything okay it's fine uh
the heating pad is helping that's good
that's what I find help sometimes I just
twist my backward and it just
hurts for like a week and the heating
pad is the only thing that helps I find
I also get this thing called sciatic
sciatica
um I've had it for like three days it's
been really awful is that's like what
nerve pinch right yeah and is that in
your back
it's like in my ass
sciatica yes
are you taking Tylenol or Ibuprofen
uh no
thank God bro no I'm like you with
tattoos man I just it's it's light work
I got Advil thank you you want me to
grab some later the insta card do you
want like Icy Hot or something uh I put
some on earlier thank you though okay
cool do you find icy hot works I put
that on I'm like this stuff is not
serious this is like silly no I think it
works okay I totally love it yeah just
like Shaq because it's not really hot
it's just feels cool because it's wet
I don't think it just feels cool because
it's wet because it doesn't really like
it it has stuff in it that I feel it on
like the inside of my muscle it like
feels very warm really I never got that
I never got that from it I wish I did
you ever accidentally get it on your
private area
bro how do you accidentally get it on
your dick man I slept the story is it
wasn't my dick it was more my balls
um I was applying some on my neck yeah
and I had to go take a piss
and I didn't wash my hands and it got
got on you know the area and what was
that like for you it wasn't fun how long
did it uh tingle for it was a couple
hours oh
wait why are you grabbing your balls
when you're fast you got it man it's a
good time you don't got it yeah wait
your cupping okay that's crazy
you know you're pulling it out of your
pants you know like
I understand yeah you never know yeah I
mean I had a similar experience I'm sure
I've told this before but one time I was
cooking in college really hot
there was a period where we're just
cooking the hottest food possible we
were using like Habaneros and jalapenos
and just like cooking it with sausages
for no reason and then I went home later
that day and I guess I didn't wipe my
hands good enough and uh my dick started
burning so bad and I was like what is
happening then I understood is from the
spicy that was on my hand still and then
I I swear to you it was it was so
painful I was I had a little hand fan
there in my little it was just a little
room in the dorm a one-person room and I
was just pointing it at my dick
trying to cool it off all night it was
so bad oh that's hot that's funny you
say that because the exciting thing
happened to me when I took the Hot Chip
I must have at some point during the day
touched my willy
after the hospital really and it's so
weird that skin just absorbs it it's
weird but I was curious if um it came
through my pee because I felt like I had
to clean I don't know about that one I
feel like I cleaned my hands but still
look it's under your nails yeah you know
yeah I like I definitely wash my hands
too but I guess not enough damn that's
crazy so how was that was that very
painful I took showers like a long just
kept showering but it didn't help no
I'm saying uh you can uh have spicy pea
whoa spicy pea yeah interesting yeah so
that sounds horrible yeah that's what I
think happened though can you cut the a
b please
what's going on man
what do you mean
did you eat gluten or something your
face I'm sunburned oh you're burned yeah
I'm like we're super burned all right
yeah is that okay you okay what happened
I Lena was going tanning and uh I was
breaking out so I'm like I'll go
with her and I never go to tanning booth
so I underestimated uh we went to a
tanning book yeah in a booth
so wait what do you wear when you go in
there are you naked
uh well I usually I would keep my boxers
on because I've gone in the past but uh
I forgot that I'm not supposed to the
hair stylist Jess told me not to expose
my hair to any like Rays like that
um so I put the boxers over my head holy
and I was butt ass naked it was a
good time so you had those UV light
lights blasting your dick no I help I
held my dick the whole time you covered
it with your hands holy that sounds
like a really comforting wait are you
gonna have weird ass tan lines of your
arms over your chest yeah it's it's
really weird my tan lines my it's the
sort of the opposite under my pants like
my ass is super burned because it's
never been exposed to the Sun and then
you can see where it cuts off where like
the boxes weren't and that's where the
burn stops oh hold on this this this
service doesn't make sense to me why
would you go in there and burn don't
they know how much the sizzle you for
yeah I mean I haven't gone in a long
time but like when I went back in
Michigan the last time I went I remember
doing like the full time but everybody's
different I learned okay so how long
were you in there for uh 12 minutes
that's it that's so wild to me that's
yeah you've got to be yeah that is 12
minutes did that to you
yeah
bro your DNA is getting blasted apart in
there I'm scared for you
they turned that off holy
it's a grill is it hot in there is it
just UV
no it's not hot there's like a big fan
it was a stand-up bed but I'm hot right
now my face is burning you
basically went into like a radioactive
uh
you went into a nuclear reactor
literally yeah no it was I was wearing
like sweatpants last night and I had to
undo the little tie because like just
going pee like going past my my uh
thighs right here
oh man
shavola or something be careful with
that stuff dude yeah I don't I don't
ever go yeah I know it's dangerous I
guess it wouldn't make much sense to
wear sunscreen in there
yeah maybe maybe not actually I don't
know tanning lotion because SPF maybe uh
maybe the SPF will work and then you'll
get a healthy I don't know I wonder if
people do do that someone says you may
have radiation poisoning Maybe
I may have something
oh hey I was I was planning a trip
to Chernobyl to work on my tan you want
to come
I was gonna Chill on the Dome my when I
was younger and I tanned the first time
I think it was like
maybe I was just started college I was
around the Jersey short time and uh I my
dad found out and he got mad about it
he's like oh you're gonna get a mole on
your ass and um
obviously that's just him being a
Millions from parent but because of that
I've always been a little bit scared uh
if I do tan that I'd get a mole on my
ass or something so just your ass or or
My
okay so that's why I was I was covering
it the whole time isn't there a towel or
something that you could cover I mean it
just seems wild that you're holding your
junk and you're covering your body seems
stressful you got underwear on your head
it was a lot it was a lot I burned so
easily here I got to carry on all this
everywhere I got the 100. the
hot it's hard to find I have that for
the kids yeah I I can go outside like 10
minutes and then come in and be
completely red I can I tell you
something though yeah
that's the smart everyone should do that
yeah the sun is the enemy it really is
sunscreen every day you do is it in your
moisturizer yep good for you stop the
Sun for me yeah I don't around with
this song I ain't gonna lie I used to
use uh sunscreen moisturizer but then uh
I was getting weird things on my face so
I had to switch off it
but yeah stay out of the sun guys if you
want to age gracefully I think that's
like the number one thing to do
and also not get skin cancer that helps
skin cancer is easy though they just
shave that off now
you know my dad's got skin cancer like
10 times really maybe not that many but
he used to suntan a lot when he was
younger now he's getting like freaking
all over him you know smash that
button my mom had it once too
it's real easy though right they take
care of it yeah depending on what kind
it is yeah if as long as you don't catch
it like super super late I think that
it's it's like easy to get rid of that'd
be a hell of a way to die though man
skin cancers it's like oh
definitely happens I mean oh yeah for
sure it happens it's the most common
form of cancer
skin cancer
good for you love loubout Brothers I can
I can't even drive without my arms
burning when I feel that too yeah when I
drive to work there's so much sun on my
hands and my wrist I I find myself
lubing them up I have one of these in my
cars too slap that on every time that's
smart
that's good skincare brother thank you
dog
thanks dog good skin care brother did we
order the scale Olivia
yeah yeah it'll be here so exciting it's
very very exciting yeah how about this
then whoever wins gets to decide what
we'll get for lunch
okay sure better not be a solid well I
don't know it's whoever depends on who
wins whoever wins all right there's no
complaining there's no deliberation if
this is a one person decision okay love
it
I think I did really well I'm excited
all right so um wow that was a fun I'm
glad everyone's doing well sorry Ian I
guess he's not doing well
it's all right thank you
would lidocaine work I know a nurse
Ian I wish you the best I'll give it a
shot
it sucks there's not better options for
pain management it's like heating pad
ibuprofen or like Fentanyl
that's it that's it
it's like damn isn't there a little bit
in between you know uh
come on get some options here
but that's what it is guys
life is suffering that's what they say
that's what they said that's what
Siddhartha said anyway
it's true but that guy didn't know
you knew a thing or two
you knew a lot about nothing exactly
thank you
thank you I'm kidding ice respect
Siddhartha and Buddha and all that stuff
oh yeah life is suffering all right so
Friday is going to be the subathon yes
um
did okay so here I mean again we're
talking about membership drives
you know I'm constantly talking about
the perks that come with memberships you
know you got access to Discord you get
the members only live stream on Tuesdays
you get um my phone number correct you
get my
address and now I'm excited to announce
a new perk
as of this
yesterday Tuesday you get my credit card
very exciting uh to all of our members I
mean and in a sense it pays for itself
folks it's a it's a risk-free membership
yeah I showed my credit card like a
idiot dude and I swear I'm not
doing this on purpose
uh and what are we gonna do luckily it
was I guess small and small enough and
fast enough that it was not legible yeah
you had it in the picture in picture
mode uh which means your little box was
quite small and so it was compressed
enough that you couldn't make out the
numbers even if you zoomed way in thank
God but if you were full screen I think
yeah people would have had it oh yeah
definitely
it was close even like that but
you know I haven't got any weird charges
or anything so I think I'm good
I'm trying to pull up the close-up there
it is so everyone was really trying to
CSI this but I'll tell you what guys
all the king's horses all the kings of
AI
they couldn't Crack the Code baby oh
there it is it looks good
they said they enhanced it with AI but
it was just that lady Ethel what's your
name Lorraine Lorraine Lorraine Babs no
pain Lorraine Ruth no pain Lorraine
so that's an exciting announcement for
all of our members thank you guys
what are we gonna what are we gonna do
about Tuesdays
it just keeps escalating it's part of
the thrill I mean you you have gotten
away with it for a while but eventually
one of these really the phone number
thing really absolute travesty that did
up your life a decent amount yeah
the phone number people said the credit
card's worse I disagree because with a
debit card or a credit card you can
cancel it you can get all the money you
could contest all the charges you know
it's a pain in the ass but the phone
number dude right that my life up
man
hmm
so we'll see I mean I don't I don't know
what could possibly it could escalate
more than it has I mean what more do I
have I'm afraid you're gonna
you're gonna flash somebody
dick I feel like that's the next
escalation
not intentionally but like in in you're
always sitting in the chair no but with
your legs up like this and you know it's
just going to be the wrong angle and
boom there it is listen
I know what I'm doing when it comes to
sitting funny like you are quite
experienced yeah I'm pretty confident in
that okay I mean here's some of the
pictures Dan was talking when people
look up I just hit my balls people
really comment for me after this
membership one man I gotta say Howie and
tana were talking about
me alive
and I tuned in which was a really funny
meta weird thing but I was just I was
hungry and I was having a bowl of cereal
you know sue me sorry for being a human
being 10 and how we are talking about
how hot and glamorous Ela is while Ethan
watches hunched over slurping milk out
of a plastic container like a goblin
yeah
[Applause]
and she's so hot
thinking hot
are you guys watching me watch Howie
why are you eating out of a Tupperware
it's just it's just what it is you never
eat out a tupperware uh not when I have
access to a bowl bowls are and sometimes
not as good because you have the high
walls it's lightweight you've got the
extra safety on the high walls it's
Superior I feel like in some cases the
Tupperware it looks like you're eating
English it looks like you're eating
leftover milk yeah
it's like I'm eating leftover milk yeah
but like it's chunky yeah yeah what's
the Tupperware so good luckily leftovers
that was good though man it was like
this
it was good cereal boy God damn
what what kind of cereal I'm trying to
remember it was some cranberry
brand cranberry honey oh
situation foreign
with cranberries Raisin Bran with
cranberries but not really that yeah
that does sound good hold it up let me
see the cover
sorry that sounds
delish
what you're against it sounds full of
fire thinking about holding your tongue
no you got to see the whole package
because it has all kinds of treats and
treasures in it okay
treats and treasures and treasures I
mean besides the cranberries and the
raisins yeah there's a little granola
treats in there oh I eat granola
every now and then it's not a okay
that's a fever
it is a green behind fever very sugary
looks pretty good get down with it I
don't think it was that it was a
different one that one it's better than
that one okay anyway it sucks here's
more people coming after me Dan thinks
my nuts are gonna fall out people are
saying I'm aching them
listen guys I don't have to do this
episode
new ick unlocked the way you're holding
your toe this is that what it's about
girl habitat okay yeah
yeah
is this not what you want
when you go to the zoo don't you want to
see the animals and their
natural habitats
exactly it's more interesting right
and then there's more I guess uh
I guess that was it oh by the way just
on a side note this guy's so funny we
talk about Ben select like stealing
everyone's content this guy he he
impersonated him perfectly
verbatim and covered his face perfectly
in every shot
It's amazing uh how good he is
all right let's check it out it's uh the
scumbag dad I love him I've been
watching him for so long okay that's
great this is I was really impressed by
this
it's crazy they
yeah that's pretty much perfect the way
the veins of the leaf align on the
creases of the hand I'm very proud of
myself
oh he's so good but it's the most
efficient way open my mailbox today to
receive a package that is honestly
awesome plus my ring at the workshop
founded days later in one of our crib
mats that's wild pretty good right I am
inside your walls bin that's high level
parody good for you uh scumbag dad
that's like his whole thing doing like
meta parody because so many levels
deeper than that sometimes check them
out dude's funny
okay so there you go
[Music]
uh we'll get to that okay let's thank
our sponsors then we can get into some
stories
uh we just have one sponsor so stick
around to thank expressvpn
[Music]
come on the internet's a dangerous place
y'all don't want to go in unprotected do
you man no
that's where expressvpn comes in do you
go to the bathroom and you close the
door behind you of course you do because
you don't want random pacifiers looking
in on you God forbid there's a little
crack and you catch eyes
horrific there's nothing worse
than this you see this
[Music]
let me move your eye back and forth so
you can kind of try to see some kind of
motion
let's close the gap with expressvpn
your privacy is important online and
offline that's why I use expressvpn and
you should too
using the internet without expressvpn is
like going to the bathroom and not
closing the door how is that well your
internet service provider knows every
single website you visit
they can sell that information to ad
companies and Tech Giants who use your
data to Target you nobody's getting my
data unless they pay me pay need that's
my data expressvpn creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet so your online activity
can't be seen by anyone works on phones
tablets
laptops routers
[Music]
uh maybe not tablets I added that I
don't know if it works on tablets but
definitely phones laptops and routers
routers protect the tablet
true so everyone who shares your Wi-Fi
is protected all you gotta do
is fire up expressvpn app click one
button and it's as easy as close in the
bathroom door
that is surprisingly hard when you have
two young boys though I'll tell you
getting in the bathroom for a private
moment is one of the hardest things I do
every night
I need expressvpn to keep them away
guys listen right now get an extra three
months of expressvpn for free
by going to expressvpn.com H3 one more
time that's expressvpn.com H sleep for
three extra months free
expressvpn.com H3 thank you to our
wonderful sponsor we love you so much
please consider supporting them if
you're in the market or interested in a
VPN
lightning
expressvm Express viewing does go hard
like that I just use expressvpn the
other day actually
or to watch a documentary that was on uh
that was on a uh European Public Access
thing that's everything I love that yep
was it a BBC One no it was uh yeah the
Roger Stone one it was a Danish oh yeah
what's the deal I the Americans can't
watch the Roger Stone it's like that's
kind of weird it was excellent by the
way it's so good right I told Cam to
watch and he checked it out and I used
expressvpn there you go yeah
I want to watch that now what's it
called
it's shoot what is it called uh because
there's two
um I'll look it up right now
Roger Stone Danish doc uh a storm portal
a storm Fort old is what it's called
okay
yeah they are with him the entire
election and uh oh yeah it's crazy dude
it's very insightful about when are we
gonna get access to that uh it's doing
uh film festivals right now okay
um and it will likely get distribution
in the United States soon but for now it
is available
in Europe
when we get in that Casey dock
I don't know if that's ever happening
dude damn at this point oh I forgot
about that I mean at this point like
what's the deal I don't think anyone
wants to buy it
I don't know uh maybe maybe you should
just release it
that's what I used on YouTube also it's
been so long now I Missed The Mark with
that one I wish Casey would just drop it
let's drop it I mean I've watched it I
watched it right right
hey
all right moving on
um
[Music]
you guys know Buffalo Exchange right
it's a thrift store uh yeah it's like a
nice second hand it's like
I I don't like it honestly it's too
expensive I don't you can't call it a
thrift store it's not a thrift it's a
second hand it's a second hand store
that is almost as expensive as coin when
you cook a buffalo so well okay yeah but
I guess they're they're real popular and
they're everywhere they are popular
Buffalo
and so yeah
somebody wrote this about their local
Buffalo Exchange
they says they don't take Teddy fresh
because of the owner
I was like what the man listen to
this
today I went to Buffalo Exchange in
Boston
to sell clothing one of which was an old
Teddy fresh shirt that no longer fits me
probably because they lost weight skinny
Legend
manager said she doesn't take Teddy
fresh anymore because the owner is too
controversial she even said not Ila his
wife but Ethan you know again it's like
since when did we punish
people for the for the supposed crimes
of their partner when do we ever do that
why does Eli have to get the brunt of
that it's stupid for sure you are a
part owner of Teddy fresher you know I'm
not involved in the day I know it's it's
thing obviously but okay so let's say I
have equity in it what do you want I
think you need to divest
okay I divest officially I dive in there
you go now it should be fine send that
clip to uh to Buffalo I'm divested I
Ethan Klein am divested
and I was like honestly I do not know
but okay she even cited that they also
don't take rip and dip he beats his wife
I don't know or Yeezy for obvious
reasons
due to the are you on the level of
beating a wife or becoming a Neo-Nazi
that's what I'm wondering I don't think
so he says due to the ownership which I
feel Ethan is not comparable to at all
has anyone else had this happen I know
Ethan isn't brand friendly per se but it
seems a little Overkill to knocks up
secondhand Teddy fresh things that just
seemed that's a that particular employee
that day or manager or whatever yeah
this dude beats his wife this one's an
active Neo-Nazi oh yeah and this guy
made a joke that was a little offensive
one time stop what did I do did I kill
somebody
hahaha why am I such a bad guy and you
know it's like the right wing people
they have no problem hating me and I get
it but even the libs want to uh they
don't want me either
well we don't we know nothing about this
person
maybe they're Maga here's what I'll say
I don't know what that what is you
trying to say with this cam
I don't know
I get it what are you trying to say yes
you guys are cute together pictures
worth a thousand words we don't have all
the time for that are you calling me a
The Missing Link we gotta we gotta move
on we gotta there's no time to analyze
this right it looks like the scale is
here by the way hey exciting but you
know I see this stuff it's just you know
I don't know why I get this I'm such a
villain people think I'm such a
villain I mean what have I done well
don't go to Buffalo Exchange anyways
they're overpriced there you go
them go to your local uh second hand
store your local vintage shop top
comment well even dude Buffalo thrift
stores have gotten stupid expensive too
uh yeah a lot of the bigger ones yeah
like when me and Ila were in New York we
went to a thrift store to get jackets I
feel like it's probably like a big city
thing too like the thrift stores in La
kind of suck like that but um I feel
like in most towns is you can find and
there are ones in La that are still
you know maybe you're right is it New
York thing probably
but the it was like a hundred dollars
even I was like what the hell because uh
who's that helping there's one famous
One in La that is
insanely expensive talk about iguanas
yeah yeah guanas is yeah and they have
cool stuff but is that that massive
place like a massive wear there's a few
of them it's not like super super
massive but it's quite big and they have
a lot of uh
they have a lot of pretty wild stuff I
mean the thing is a lot of the stuff at
iguanas really is vintage it's like
coats from the 70s and stuff and like I
guess I kind of get probably that would
be expensive is if it's in good
condition but yeah it's not very
affordable well shout out to the Super
Trooper I love what they said
she said
do you know uh not Ela but Ethan he's
too controversial you know and I was
like honestly I do not know but okay
thank you thank you who's new
cauliflower I love you
top comment she probably moonlights at
the Vatican interesting
[Music]
that's an interesting thought cam what
are we gonna do about this what are you
gonna do about it oh yeah that's your
city yeah it wouldn't happen if I was
still around you think so oh yeah oh
yeah hey I'll you don't want to take
Teddy fresh somebody's gonna take a ride
down the slide
put some respect them we'll take him out
to the slide
grease it up
show them the last ride of his life
throw on a high visibility vest
we dig the shallow grade at the bottom
of the slide shoots him right in it
I can understand why you don't take rip
and dip but you yourself may be ripped
and dipped if you catch my dream
uh they better this person said they
better not have American Peril
Ambercrombie Nike Hugo Boss right
I mean Hugo Boss I think I'll watch the
documentary that guy was like a straight
up
nothing I don't want to be talking at a
turn but he was like he designed for the
essay yeah no the SS uniforms were Hugo
Boss oh that's fine
no but also he was um
maybe I'm thinking someone else
the misuse of 140 polish and I'm sorry
polish and 40 French Forest workers
there was one big designer who was uh
like
essaying and her and sexually harassing
his employees
uh there's a there's enough oh maybe it
was um
yeah I don't want to say yeah they're
wrong yeah exactly yeah people mad but
it's on Netflix maybe you could look
here let's see Netflix
designer
you and you guys can do that I'm looking
it up
Peter Nygaard
what was the company investigation of
Peter Niger that's the first thing that
popped up uh Swedish out last name yeah
it was one of the really big trafficking
ring really really big names
I mean Nike has like slave labor
people in the chat are saying that too I
think it I think yeah I think this is
them
wait what's the aim of his company
nothing's coming up but the the thing is
called unseemly oh that's a good name
yeah
Netflix documentary
exposes criminalization
that's such a good name
so wait Peter okay maybe this was
Alexander Wang I'm also seeing a bunch
in the chat uh
there's a lot of names being thrown out
it's a thing yeah industry is kind of
riddled with it so definitely yeah
[Applause]
all right so let's get a shot so we can
see the live
tally here now love is going to
he's going to step on the scale this is
a human grade scale right yep for humans
that we've ordered from
a reputable store
now love is going to step on the scale
we're going to see where the number
lands there'll be one winner who will
decide the fate of all of our lunches
this is exciting between your legs
waiting for the cameras to be set up
we've got guesses all over the board
from 160 was that UCam 160 or 165 yeah
that's kind that's kind
I want to throw in a mixed up answer
here and say you lost weight yeah yeah
so we have we have numbers ranging from
160 all the way up to
178 which was my best that's pretty hard
I
that would be worrying it would be okay
well let's see are we good
we are we are setting up
love has been enjoying himself since
he's moved to uh California uh sure have
sure love says he knows he's gained some
weight
yeah but how much he's uncertain of you
know last time I was here last year I
actually lost weight because we were
doing a lot of activities like
going places right and I lost a lot of
weight there interesting probably seven
pounds
so
what's the range we're looking at here
five would be okay 10 would be
concerning
I'm not concerned I just
it's funny I really don't care you don't
care yeah
love the pot the body positivity coming
out of love right now
I am under the impression though maybe
in five years within five years I should
care well you know when it's time to
care yeah yeah exactly I'll know
all right love step on up
to the human grade scale
[Music]
all right so let's get a close-up on the
um
the counter there
okay love is going to be stepping on
here here goes
both both feet both feet right on there
okay here we go
178.6
178 that's like exactly my guess
uh wait I said 170 I said 178 Ethan got
it wow
wow that's wide
wow very nice
178 now again you're wearing your whole
outfit when you weighed yourself at 166
were you wearing an outfit no I was I
wasn't wearing a hoodie I wasn't wearing
shoes and I was probably wearing shorts
and no beanie you know who guessed two
pounds less than you
well so I'm probably 170.
yeah that's not how it works Olivia yeah
I mean that's fine nice try so what do
you guys think 175 176 probably without
a thick hoodie Oh I thought we weren't
counting no I know I I think you win oh
I don't know maybe like three pounds
probably yeah so 175 okay you want to
take it off and let's take off this
hoodie You Wanna Get Naked let's take
off the beanie let's take off the
glasses
you want to drop to just your trousers
that's that's fine create yourself
Wednesday
ow Jesus okay so now Palpatine
over here love is disrobing hey B just
shocked the hell out of me love is
taking off the hoodie which is heavy
it's a heavy hoodie his glasses got
paddle coming out hopefully they're okay
are they okay
good this was also shoes yeah shoes for
sure are those pants heavy or are they
you want to take them off
okay let's see here we go one more time
174.
that's like four pounds damn in a hoodie
and shoes
that's how you know you're getting
quality with Teddy fresh it's true man a
thick fabric baby
wow okay that's really a just a good
huge
173 so that would mean you gained
seven pounds
and you've been here for how long
four months thank you
it's not bad yeah
yeah that's not too bad I want to say
I'm not
there it is guys but unfortunately uh
that's not the rules we established
which makes me the winner yeah uh by
exact guess yeah so you get to decide
lunch because you guys weighed me like
you guys lifted me with that arm so I
think right exactly thank you yeah so if
it's up to me I will and since I'm
paying I'm saying no lunch all right
no I'm kidding actually I don't know
thanks for watching everybody I don't
know what to I don't know what to do now
you guys oh my God it's so much pressure
you suggested Taco Bell earlier was that
coming out of a desire to eat Taco Bell
from you or were you just throwing that
out there for love
you did bring it up
I did bring it up you did bring it up
they're not paying us though yet
well let's just not say that it's Taco
Bell how many millions of dollars of
tacos have we sold
am I just talking about Taco Bell on the
show yeah dude I think a lot a lot and
then what do we get in exchange 10 gift
cards give me a break joke what's a joke
we do appreciate
our fan that works at Taco Bell
is there would everyone like Taco Bell
it's you listen you said this is a
dictatorship see now no input you
specified no input from anybody else see
now it's stressing me out in and out
could be fun in and out oh my God I
don't know if there's any even any close
to here they don't deliver
oh they don't do Postmates no I don't
think so oh
Taco Bell
McDonald's
nah what why would you always
bad here no it's not McDonald's is like
the gold standard it's like pretty
beautiful that's what we're talking
about food like it's
listen I used to be a McDonald's hater
until I started going there
and then you realize that why the golden
arches are yeah because it's they are
the gold standard and consistency
and delivery Nothing Better In The
Experience
it is McDonald's
[Music]
shame on you love
the Swedish McDonald's is good okay Zach
and Joanna yeah gold doesn't really make
a cafe best coffee man I'm telling you
just don't spill it
oh
no no Olivia do you have an idea
um
I really am cool do you have an idea do
you have an idea
talk about something fine if you guys
want to talk about I'm down for that
Bolivia has found herself in hot
possibly boiling water yes uh sometimes
speaking of boiling water
soup I don't want soup I don't know
where do you get soup I don't want soup
where do you get soup it just sounded
sweet for a second is there
soup is like a hug you know what let's
get sued let's get sued no is there a
soupery around here hold on I'm gonna
look is there supery perhaps Ramen is
that word
from soup restaurant no that's that's
has too much stuff in it I need broth
just broth brother that's kind of what I
do sometimes we could just get a vat of
matzo ball soup
restaurant near me this is what it's
gonna be
yeah it's mostly like uh
Ramen and Chinese stuff and Thai
matzo ball soup
you know in New York they had they had
soup spots and I appreciated that
like The Soup Nazi spot
and it's great it's just like from the
show you walk up
you tell them what you want
you step to the side
oh yeah
I'm not seeing any super easy damn
Deli even though you know Deli mood
a deli you like Deli I like Dallas but
so what just force everyone to eat matzo
ball soup pretty much dude split pea
soup matzo ball soup uh mushroom
Barley's good
um mushroom Barley's classic iconic soup
cabbage soup is good are you regretting
suggesting soup Olivia
um
no okay but I will take the L if we
don't want soup I'm definitely aware
that it's a very distinct craving I
don't I think it was a good I think it
was interesting people are saying Panera
I've never eaten there nope that's good
is it what's the menu here I'll send it
because that could be a soup spot it is
a it's a hot soup spot have you guys
ever heard of a place called Panera
cares
no is it Panera Bread's charity it yeah
so it's donation based and you pay based
on a donation but there's no that you
don't yeah you don't have to pay what
they suggest
they opened one in Dearborn which was
the worst move they could have
ever done and because in our hometown
people would grab like 50 worth of food
and put in like five bucks and it closed
down in like a year
so wait Panera they did like a charity
one yeah there's a few there's a few
Panera carers I guess
um a Panera Terror Panera cares oh the
Panera the banera Terra
care yeah that's the name of the
Dearborn one so but like in a sense
though why would you
know I'm just kidding
um yo these tubes look good
broccoli cheddar
we like that
yeah now I'm gonna say this because they
have an extensive menu everybody has to
get soup
they're known for their bread bowls or
bread bowls yeah you can do a bread bowl
I sanction that
cream of chicken and wild rice that
sounds kind of interesting
Bistro French onion soup
wow look at those bowls sounds like
elevated dining
these bowls look like straight cream
yeah they're all different flavors
I don't think so I took it off real fast
mac and cheese in a bread bowl what
yo it's really good but it's super
fattening that one yeah it looks heavy
dude that's good it's only 10 bucks for
this thing
some of them are nine dollars for a
bread bowl soup Panera makes magic
Panera's Panera cares super overpriced
yeah Panera cares wait super overpriced
it's soup unless this Panera carrots
then you can just Rob wait what at nine
dollars that's like nothing for a for a
bowl
that seems like a good deal for a whole
ass loaf of bread
with soup
dish or like side dish
maybe you're right a bread bowl that's
big oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
um
okay so I'm gonna get one of these we're
gonna do we're gonna get soup
we must get soup
yeah
creamy does anyone have this cream cream
of chicken and wild rice soup I've never
had that one
that looks kind of good french onion is
broccoli cheddar soup I love but
sometimes it goes sideways
sometimes it's too heavy and you can't
really work through it
you know what I mean yeah they have like
a corn soup that's super good like a
spicy corn I didn't see that one on the
list can I hit you with some uh some
info right here absolutely
I'm a supator I don't like soup like at
all
you would
not any soup
not a thing you never met a soup you
liked what I mean it's Ramen soup yes I
mean it's like a noodle soup I like it
for the noodles there's noodles and
soups like matzo balls noodles a big
part of I guess that's soup that I love
I guess that's a soup that I like then I
take it back yeah it's okay but like
tradition all the ones that you're
listening like none of that sounds
appealing to me I'm looking at this
broccoli cheddarsing all this
vegetables from every single one
loves about the vegetables Dan you can't
hate on that I want I want food I don't
want a drink you know what I mean I
don't want my food being a drink they've
got food too they have a bunch of
sammies he said I had to get soup yeah
but you could get soup to match your
sandwich
you must order soup this is a call with
peace and love
either soup or nothing
no you can get whatever you want
oh but now I feel like I have to get
sued I'm so committed to the idea
admitted to the soup that's where I'll
get soup and that'll be enough I'm not
gonna Force you guys but I would
appreciate if you did get soup I've been
curious to try a tomato soup in a bread
I love the tomatoes from Panera Dan I
don't want you to order something you're
not gonna like so you can go ahead and
not get soup but I will take note of it
I'm gonna be docked for that I'm just
gonna say I will take note all right
fair enough Eli is sent to the group
chat did love ever have McDonald's
breakfast ask him because of McDonald's
slander yeah the breakfast is what got
me into McDonald's okay so let me I
don't like egg I don't like cheese so
you want never mind so what happens
nothing yeah nothing never mind do they
have sweet breakfast yeah they have no
breakfast okay they do actually what
kind
yo their breakfasts are crazy man they
got like the hot cakes
yo you know what I just learned
McDonald's has a breakfast burrito no
that's gotta be like at specific spots I
they've had it since like the 80s I
looked it up I was in disability I've
never seen me neither
isn't that weird
that is weird
it's like secret menu item what
hold on let me look at this
let's look up uh
McDonald's breakfast burrito breakfast
here's everything on the breakfast menu
sausage burrito there it is oh sausage
burrito I think I did know about this
yeah I was like did they recently do
this and I looked it up and uh it's been
around forever it doesn't look that good
huh
no too the particularly
isn't that weird though
yeah that is weird no idea if you're
looking for an El Primo breakfast man
two sausage egg and cheese McMuffins
take off half the bread
you're good to go the sausage egg
McMuffin is nuts that goes crazy
hard yeah right so I'm gonna get uh
I'm gonna get the cream of chicken and
wild rice please God be good all right
I don't know if that's a wrist Collard
cream does anyone know about this soup
and chat like am I making a mistake
you know
can you get croutons
I want it in a bread bowl too
I can place the order if you guys can
tell me those oh thank you Lena thank
you of course you know it'll be funny I
don't really want soup I'd rather get
something else I gotta get something
else
on soup now if soup is not your truth
soup is not your choice give me that
soup
okay got it is your truth these
flatbreads look kind of interesting
though
I never been here I have never seen
their men it's a whole new world Panera
Bread they do bread huh that's their
whole thing yes
chipotle chicken and bacon flatbread
what the I think it's kind of
overrated in my opinion but um
uh Ela is also saying that um we need to
move the podcast early enough so that we
can order a McDonald's breakfast for
love we're starting early on Friday I
think it ends at 10 yeah
that's perfect timing yeah get it right
at the end and then we start it's all
for you McDonald's breakfast so we're
gonna order without cheese or an egg or
we'll get ones without cheese oh nice
and without egg nice there's got to be
something I think I think I brought
loved one was it McGriddle or something
but I had cheese on it yeah yeah that's
right he bailed he bailed I had to build
I took him I was like oh this guy
she's on there
what do you feel when you eat cheese
what is it I don't like cheddar cheese
what about
American mozzarella is good
the Mexican mix uh that you can get
first what's the problem that because
that one's good melted like they
don't use cheddar they use American epic
American I don't like the orange juice
it's orange as yeah orangest
I don't taste good Love's palette is
very uh unique yeah yeah specific all
right get me that soup
camera soup you sound thrilled no I'm
I'm not actually up into a corner
yeah
thanks Olivia
somebody's got to get soup
maybe there's a salad I can get I don't
know I'm just gonna get a loaf of
sourdough bread
that's fire yep it comes as a side
I mean not a Sourdough I mean that's
sourdough
get that with butter just hit it
all right let's move it along and move
on a Greek salad too
this looks kind of good I might become a
banana boy I might become a Panera let's
let's not be Hasty I used to have Panera
all the time at school but it looks so
good I love it yeah same I like spots
like this where it's like not that nice
but it's consistent yeah good Smoky
flavor with good Smoky flavors it's
classic that's kind of like um this
podcast in a way right where that's like
not that good but it's like consistent
we're always there yeah
[Applause]
yeah but for the most part right you
have an off day but you still come back
that's a good analogy did you get that
solid order
yeah I got it you said a Greek salad yes
please thank you so much
[Music]
um God should I get a flatbread pizza
too I know I'm not gonna eat all this
but I just want to try it because I'm a
Panera head I was thinking I wanted a
creamy tomato soup but I also want pizza
so maybe we share the picture of the
pizza cool the flatbread one yeah or I
mean the margarita or either that one or
the pepperoni one I was interested in
you know how I feel about pepper I know
so the other one yeah I'm opposed all
right Margarita let's keep it classy
sweet very classy all right thank you
wow that was a long order
oh yeah
might be a record you know we should we
should
we should see when's the longest we've
spent ordering during our live podcast
that might have been the record that
took a while it was like 13 or first and
then we're still not moving on we're now
we're talking about it what other show
would have the balls to order lunch live
for 30 minutes with 45 000 people
watching yeah nobody that's what Panera
Bread energy nobody would dare
someone says I'm obsessed with Ethan
finding Panera I think Ela would love
Panera I think she would too that's the
other thing I feel like we could bond
over Panera in fact I think I'm gonna
get it for dinner tonight too
I'm all in they have good drinks I think
you would like they have good drinks
tea lemonade green tea is so good well
do you want anything she's watching
apparently you should get her the the
ice cream tea that is really good hold
on let me look at the secret is to mix
it with lemonade but I think you can
only do that if you're there blood
orange shark Splash so what is that
blood orange charge splash
strawberry lemon mint charged why are
they charging it what does that mean I
don't like that what it's charged mean
maybe like just caffeine I think oh is
that what it means wait it says free for
subscribers you can subscribe to Panera
Bread
that's sick I'd sub to Panera I'm
subbing bro
baby all right give me one of these
check this out zero calories dude blood
orange charged Splash zero sugar
you got that
dude I'm getting one of those too you
got that Lena thank you so much thank
you oh my god dude Panera is like out of
this it's out of control you guys
oh yeah the green smoothie is it's going
to arrive and it's going to taste like
I'm gonna hate it no no no no no no
all right let's move on
thank you what a what a meme how
exciting
what an exciting podcast it is yes I do
LOL oh what does she want what do you
want
tell Lina what you want Ela and then you
could come eat with me on the show
that'd be fun
Ila are you excited about Panera Bread
like I am what you want
uh let's keep going we've got a lot of
good stuff here we got a Crowder update
I saw him on Twitter or maybe it was
Instagram he uploaded this clip
because he is now offering advice on
dating of course to his audience members
he of course who was the left by his
wife for being abusive
uh and blowing cigars cigar smoke in her
face while she was pregnant oh yes like
Superwoman like this woman who's like
successful hot and then they're actually
in the relationship and they're
experiencing what it's like to be around
somebody who has like a lot going on and
a lot of whatever and they start to get
resentful and you're like but I thought
that's why you liked it I thought that's
what you liked about me it was how
opinionated I was they don't care here's
what men actually I mean so I see your
point right like it's an interesting
point I understand uh
but now Crowder's take is real
juicy value in women according to Pew
research physical attractiveness is
right up there but right next to it is
empathy nurturing kindness intelligence
honesty morality professional or
financial success are now down to eight
percent independent self-reliance six
percent we do men don't care don't care
women stop with this job
we don't care
right and that should be the only reason
that anybody should want to Aspire to
anything right he I love how we think of
a man of course Crowder
um I love how he's just speaking for all
men we do not care about you we do not
care about your job we do not care about
your opinions we want we see you as a
hole that's it appreciate if you
didn't talk as much too that's why you
won't even get his wife a car they're
sharing a car oh right what a nasty
freak he is
what is this Pew I wanna I wanna take
yeah I was just gonna try to find this
yeah
more like pu research
Superwoman like this woman who's like
successful hot and then they're actually
in the relationship and they're
experiencing what it's like to be around
somebody who has like a lot going on and
a lot of whatever and they start to get
resentful and you're like but I thought
that's why you liked it like I thought
that's what you liked about me was how
opinionated I was they don't also like
she's not don't take it so personally
Crowder she's not talking about you
she's talking about dude she's dated you
know by the way she wouldn't do you
think that she would
hold on crowder do you think you have a
chance with her yeah Crowder maybe back
up on this one step that brother
I don't think you have much say in this
yeah dude you know what I mean come on
I don't care here's what you're wearing
a shirt that says I'm pro-gun change my
mind I mean dude
I don't think anyone's looking to
you you know what if you don't want a
girlfriend you're doing such a chicken
right right right right right right
right and actually valued in women
according to Pure research physical
attractiveness is
so this is from what years is from
uh 2017
2017 uh-huh
not the most one uh thing that I'm
immediately noting about this is that
the question
isn't what you value it's what you think
Society values ah so that already uh
kind of undercuts the point that he's
trying to make here
um not that he cares valued most in men
honest morality honest interesting
professional financial success ambition
strength
hard work physical attractiveness
God bless man look how far down that is
uh God bless women I mean and wait a
minute here's another hole in that whole
Theory because of the way that this is
worded on it this is the question is
what
you think Society values most in men and
women these aren't
unless I'm mistaken these questions
aren't divided by men men answered for
men yes yeah right that's what I was
thinking I was like man this is what men
think you people are not thinking about
the question most valued in women
physical attractiveness empathy kindness
nurturing intelligence intelligence is a
problem I don't did he mention
intelligence I don't think he did he's
he glossed over that one hold on right
up there but right next to it is empathy
nurturing kindness intelligence honesty
morality professional or financial
success or now down and then why is he
showing cardi B
here's an example of a woman nobody
would ever want to eight percent
independent self-reliance six percent we
do men don't care you're trying to make
yourself attracted to a man and the way
wait Heap okay let me emphasize what
we're looking at he posted this Crowder
edited in a clip of Andrew Tate walking
in slow-mo into his clip
yeah he's that is so pathetic that is so
pathetic
say that a man makes himself attractive
to you what are you doing why are you
showing this is this an example of an
attractive attractive men apparently
hottest guy in the world is this an
example of an attractive man no right
not according to Crowder
we don't care okay we just want to sex
traffic you
can't deal with it yes to most women a
man who can provide a man who can
protect a man who makes a good living
that matters to you
we couldn't care less at least the guys
that are attractive that's right
there it is wonder why he's divorced
good Christian values
wonder why his ex-wife lives on the
opposite side of the country with his
two kids that he's not allowed to see
do we know that
last I read about it he wasn't he he had
no custody rights at all I'm not sure
but she took the kids to the east coast
I know that she fled from him right
which is you know
pretty good credentials
for giving advice to men and women there
it is Stephen Crowder we love you we're
all rooting for you
that Andrew Tate looks like Diglett
it's true
I've never seen that comparison before
but yeah I see it he has that kind of he
has Diglett energy oval body he's got
the
got them sit on his face I have a better
picture right here where they look like
sent in the Discord oh this is really
good girl I got this
this is really good
check it out
wait did
you just happened okay that's very funny
but also there just happened to be a
Diglett meme I saw it I saw it earlier
this morning three hours ago by Ashley
baby 420.
that's good
um
I was trying to find this clip
on the members and now we fished it up
for us all to enjoy Myron from fresh and
fit says he never had a serious
girlfriend through high school and
college in fact to his through his
entire adult life and this man has a
show giving advice to men and women
on how to date
I'm just saying there's I understand
that some people have a hard time
connecting with people in life and you
know that's that's it's sad and I and I
wish them a romance and love and a
connection but not when you're my rep
when you spend your whole career
just being a misogynistic piece of
they blaming all women because you're a
scumbag
and being the ultimate gentleman
and yes I am referring to uh the mass
shooter you get that that is the spirit
of
Myron let's listen
I'm gonna give y'all a cheat code right
now
you guys want to know why I'm successful
why I like I'm doing real well in life
right now in my teenage years are you in
my college Years
I never had a serious girlfriend bam I
never bro he's really trying to twist
that into a dub
I love coconuts going bam bam that is
copium on
that is copia Max this man is he's
trying so hard to spin that in his own
mind too you know I think it's just
about convincing himself that he's not a
total loser
dude this is why I at 38 years old have
never been in a relationship
and have a podcast that was just
demonetized by YouTube
that's why everyone wants to be like
crushing it perhaps I never took a girl
seriously ever you know what I'm saying
like where I was like she's my girl and
all this other I was always
single bro
cool okay cool very cool yes
yo girls
yo Myron say it with me girls man
they suck they're gay yeah women are gay
I have cooties
he's 35.
he's about to be a 40 year old virgin
hmm
you know relationship virgin sure that's
a huge thing I hear they make movies
about those people yeah
okay uh there it is
an ER doctor gives us input on Tylenol
versus Ibuprofen the debate's been
raging on I feel that obligated to tell
you now the final update with peace and
love I'm an ER doctor trust me on that
and the US Blaze uh the recent history
discussion about Tylenol ibuprofen could
be harmful neither are dangerous he says
both are very safe when used properly
now I'm just confused there it is I'm
not going to read the whole thing you
can read it if you want but I just want
to provide everybody
I want to say with peace and love this
is a serious message Tylenol and
ibuprofen are safe when used as directed
peace and love peace and love
now what about together
he didn't talk about together that's
right
probably shouldn't mix them I've seen
I've seen pills that is a mix of them
both in one pill are they I got it right
here
really you have it
oh no Advil it doesn't have both
though no it's dual action it has uh the
uh oh it has the same ingredient as
ibuprofen and uh Tylenol yo you've got
it right there there you go so how many
of those guys I got OG Advil too
ready to go what's the how much of those
can you take in a day
um for these I do not know
uh
uh no more than six Capitals in 24 hours
that's a lot one every four to six hours
yeah
three or more alcoholic drinks every day
while using this product Oh God
um here we have safe Moon oh we're doing
a safe moon it's just been because it
was playing the safe Moon thing I just
got curious if it had gone to the Moon
yet like the guy said it would
apparently not soon but it's good though
is that like one billion
point zero zero zero one two zero two
two one ten thousandth of a cent right
which is not bad I still got my fupa
coin I'm I'm holding total
any day now there you go nobody fear
Thailand on ibuprofen they're safe to
use
just follow the instructions man
you know how I called out Oliver tree
for posting that right wing grift
what the
what the he ripped it from like a
Neo-Nazi uh page and so now he posted a
clip of us goofing around and being
friends here it is
watch this
Oliver tree live back in this hey bro
okay now let's go to the comments
section after he courted Nazis
[Music]
Oliver tree is a Nazi sympathizer I
don't think that's true hell of a tree
going on to the scriptures podcast
okay Fuji wavy you just thought it was
dope that he was on my pocket
damn bro I thought you hated him that
was the whole reason I followed you I'm
disappointed
you're telling me that you follow people
based on how much they hate me
that's pretty sad it's an interesting
way to navigate the world
unfollowed all the comments it's crazy
Ethan is a grifter tread lightly I don't
know Rift are you running I don't know
do they even know what that means the
word has unfortunately I mean this guy
also called me a grifter
I'm not sure what they mean by that
um I don't sell slot buckets
uh dude I love you and your music but
hanging out with Ethan really it's every
comment
I saw one or two and I figured it was
funny but this is crazy Ethan Oliver
please stop doing podcasts with Ethan
he's pure cringe
all right Kevin pedo
oh pedijo sorry whenever you click their
profile there's like 15 year olds like
like whoa dude I'm so confused by Oliver
like are they cool or not
same thing with Bobby Lee I have no
clue okay that's fair to be
confused it is confusing
I don't say Ana Oliver and Ethan's jokes
bits go over people's heads they're
clearly friends
and have been for years
[Applause]
I'd comment
Alpha cuck mad in the comments so I
guess there's there's a war happening
it's a battle for the soul man that dude
needs to hit the gym yeah
you saw my flabby bodies
Ela is still insanely bad I see that's a
compliment that's a compliment yeah yes
she is bad Bobby's Bob Bobby's spitting
facts over here your girl's bad that's
pretty funny though right I mean there's
Oliver tree Nazi youth
director and coordinator
the vice president of the national uh
Socialist Party of America
and I'll tell you what you know why he
always covers his body with costumes
because he has a Giants oh
[Music]
I've seen it huge on his chest okay
that's not with that Iron Eagle and
stuff that's not true
did ELO order something Lena
what was your question did Ela order
something yeah did but I'm sending it to
the house oh she's at home yeah
wow oh I wanted to eat with her yeah
sorry wait don't order it now I wanted
to order I wanted to eat it to go to
dinner but you weren't going to be
either
she's hungry she'll be ready
this ick thing what is this is this a
reasonable eck
okay this was a post on the subway I
guess we'll all get in on this
on the top of today's uh episode where
the crew watched tick talks about X I do
recall having one ick with an X that was
so horrible that almost made me
completely lose all feelings for him wow
I'm so embarrassed to say but a couple
years ago me and my ex were sitting in
the backyard and I guess did him a
Nintendo switch feelings I remember
being so happy I felt so much relief
that he loved his gift
uh that uh but that precious moment
quickly disappeared because I kid you
not he was sitting on the corner of the
chair and his balls were hanging out
like his pants offer no support at all
and basically gave him a huge camel toe
and I felt completely grossed out and
the following week I bought him like
four pairs of pants from Levi to see if
the ick would fade but the image was
permanently great in my mind and I was
never able to recover from it that's
hilarious I kind of know what she means
I said not a good look when the balls
hang out oh yeah no they're roughly not
I mean presumably uh uh they were
familiar with the balls yeah I don't
think that was the problem right a big
ball it was just that particular uh it's
like you your dude chilling and your
balls are hanging out I mean that's just
that's just not a Vibe put your balls in
my mouth what
uh everyone wake up there's a fresh
juicy copy pasta just dropped
do you guys believe this I seems crazy I
believe it they broke up broke up
because
his balls were hanging out I believe it
well it was just it was one of the
reasons there has to be it has to be
they broke up because of that right no
that's the other thing no this was it I
believe her she got him the switch
they're having a magical moment and then
boom balls
I think it probably infantilized him and
she was just like ah right that's a baby
right
you know he's sitting there playing the
video game his balls are hanging out
he's probably got snot nose not great
it's a child needs to grow up man
how old was he put your balls away dude
sounds like he was about seven
uh I believe it though
put your balls no I definitely believe
is this a reasonable ick what do you
guys think
no um it's not reasonable but it makes
sense to me
reading it I thought it was a little
extreme but I remember in my younger
years talking to someone and they had
really bad breath just one time
and oh that's it stuck with me it I
don't know why I mean I I know yeah I
I'm the same way with the with the
breath smell yeah
so the balls is the breath yeah
when you think about it like that it
makes sense
the balls are the breath
yourself until you're on the verge of
vomiting
no
uh let's see let's get into one of our
main stories because we're going on and
on and on we're having so much fun on
and on
Jeff update let's do this dobrik update
okay
it's always nice when we get a David
dobrik update isn't it
it's been
a while it really has been he's just
been on Snapchat
he's off on his own
Smith
Jeff recently talked about how David
didn't want him to make the documentary
now he had discussed that with us also
but what's different now is that he
shared
some receipts
of text messages and videos of David's
and Natalie his assistance participation
here's a clip that uh Jeff
shared
I always wonder why does he take so long
to do this stuff man you know just don't
jump with it but he's he's not a snitch
you're not like that you know
he's a good old boy we don't snitch I
mean his his litigation is still ongoing
as far as I know yeah I think if it was
over we would have heard yeah
you guys do this tear the thing
off
you feel it yeah yeah
what this one's really I'm gonna ruin
the shirt if I pull hard sometimes yeah
yeah you all right let's see
I said just don't jump without me I
don't want this accident to turn me into
a so make sure you don't jump
without me and I said I guess this is
here's Natalie and David they came over
Watch the documentary now here's some
text message he got from Natalie
[Music]
uh here's Natalie texting with Jeff
hi I just saw Jeff's tweet
this is uh someone on Jeff's team one of
Jeff's runs oh from his people are
talking
don't want to bother him but how'd the
edit turn out
good we cut out the screenshots and
changed some verbiage
he's in bad shape today though
oh man
what does it Natalie respond okay cool
did you guys add the teaser stuff for
the positive note at the end oh my God
okay cool he's so gross he's in really
rough shape okay he's right on he's not
doing well sick all right cool how
little empathy can you have to type out
cool and like make that choice after
reading that she didn't she did chose
not to see that yeah
mean Choice she's goal driven and that's
why he likes her right mean Choice okay
cool he's in bad shape man his eye is
not healing properly he's in a really
deep depression I'm worried about him
okay cool did you guys add this this
teaser stuff for the positive note at
the end
let's just make sure we end it on a real
positive note okay all right cool
continues hi talk to Jeff yesterday and
don't want to bother him or really
anyone too much
but can't help checking in how's
everything looking for him and the next
app good gonna try and have it done and
posted by tomorrow
bro yeah this is like supposedly right
after he got out of surgery
checking in because she cares or can't
help checking in because he's putting
out an edit about her boss I mean
clearly not because she cares
that's so up
Natalie seems like a
a perfect match for David that's a great
way of putting it they really
okay cool yeah Jeffy uh it looks like he
is gonna lose the eye and um and also
his arm is going to take four years
physical therapy and um
he's crying so he's gonna be crying all
the time yeah he's gonna he's crying day
in day out he can't stop crying we're
real worried about him the life-changing
uh it's a life-changing injury okay sick
right on all right so okay so you guys
gonna do the positive thing we talked
about at the end
make sure to end on a really happy note
okay
she's basically like okay sorry or happy
for you or whatever you said yeah yeah
she said uh have a great summer have a
great summer eggs
by the way is Jeff gonna make it to our
next uh project
we're going out to the lake again to do
a redo
wow they suck oh he's a nasty
he's a real nasty one and so is she
nasty nasty
yeah it sucks for Jeff he really trusted
him you know
yep I'd never do that to you Jeff
I never even put your ass on the
excavator I'll tell you that right now
and just to give a little bit more
context of the video that's one of his
friends who he said is not involved in
the industry and was like watching this
from the outside and just thinking this
was insane and so he recorded that
little clip of like right after Jeff was
out of surgery that they're they're all
over there watching the video and not
caring about him
wow
let me watch with that con let's see I'm
lucky at good people around me that saw
this BS for what it was Jeff said I
don't want this accident to turn me into
a so make sure you don't jump
without I was so rooting for Jeff to go
in on them hard but I understand why he
did it you know I get it
but man
you should just be you should be kissing
the ground he walks on that like one he
didn't press charges he didn't sue you
on the spot he didn't talk about it for
what years or a year
they should both be so embarrassed
they're not they should be I can tell
they're they're actually I think they're
bitter
because they've been so unfairly treated
that's my impression
anyway shout out to uh dobrik we were
rooting for him
Natalie as well we're all rooting for
them
isn't that right
very good
very good we're rooting for them that's
I'm just doing the Joe Biden thing right
oh right right and he said about Trump
we're all we're I'm rooting oh we're all
rude that's my tough situation we're all
rooting for you it's my new thing that I
say to enemies of the show what a stupid
son of a we're all rooting for you
Diamond Joe
it basically means I hope they you know
button
right yep okay now here we're okay
now here we come to a really nice stupid
now here we come to a really dicey
situation Barstool Sports podcast host
off the show uh part what is it what's
it called pardon my thing part of my
take yeah part of my take
he's being canceled I know right you
apologize in advance he's getting
canceled he's getting called out he's
getting dragged for his comments about
Taylor Swift
now let me say this
I don't care what he said
he's guilty
because even the insinuation being a
Twitter uh Taylor Swift fan is like
living in like USSR it's like you don't
even ha it doesn't even matter the
accusation you're done you can't stand
against Tate
it's either Tate or Nene to life
we'll take you out back you understand
so Taylor Swift fans are going after Dan
Katz
who demanded to see a sex tape of Taylor
Swift and Travis Kelsey to confirm that
their romance is real
cats read the comment uh as the host of
part of my take days after Swift
attended Kelsey's Chief Chiefs game
against the Jets here's the clip
now I want to give you guys a trigger
warning um this may offend
um
Tate fans of which I am one
if there's one Taytay fan left it's me
bro
moments before tragedy
last photos
why is it muted it doesn't make sense
damn
Taylor Swift is a problem for the NFL we
have to unite as a as a group of fans we
can't let this happen she's bad for
football She's Gotta stop going to games
what's their next Chiefs game what is
that dollar store Stevo or not Stevo uh
steiny no not uh
Steve will do it he's like he looks just
like a dollar store Steve will do it
honey it does Steve won't do it Steve
will not do it right
Carson Daly interrupted my Sunday Night
Football this is why I fight for the NFL
people don't realize like first they
take our Sunday Night Football and we
said nothing like this is
Taylor Swift is a problem for the NFL we
have to unite as a as a group of fans we
can't let this happen she's bad for
football she's got to stop going to
games what's their next Chiefs game I
hope it's in how dare him first
of all what is the steak thing even
invoke her name in vain I am the Lord
he was pissed off because when the game
started they started with a Taylor Swift
ad from The Voice where they explain
football to swifties and that pissed God
forbid more people get into the you
don't find that amusing right well why
wouldn't you want more people watching
the game isn't that good for everyone
right
do you want less people watching because
I don't think that's good you know
right because then it goes away do you
value Community do you hate other people
that's what I'm saying
do you
it's really just that he found the
commercial annoying that's that's what's
ruining football like obviously I'm sure
he's being he's being a little
hyperbolic or whatever right yeah he's
feeling facetious he's being silly but
it's like but that's not an excuse no
he's got an evil heart there was a bunch
of people booing at the game a group of
salty men at MetLife Stadium boot a
Taylor Swift at a and their team lost
three to 24. that's what happens when
you go against Tate you lose
but like legitimately
separately from whatever what what
is wrong with that on screen
I hate her I hate women's stuff
yo she does women's stuff I don't
it's time to get canceled
[Music]
oh I'm sorry
okay
I didn't catch what you said but you hit
that trust me real fast
it was crooked so I didn't I panicked oh
just because we didn't laugh no it
wasn't bad sometimes I'm looking into
something and you know you know you know
don't you know sometimes it's just worth
doing it
I hear you all right do it we've been
good we've been so good
but I was talking about these guys a
group of salty men at MetLife Stadium
booing at Taylor Swift ad it's not even
like she's there she's paying the NFL
she's paying for organization that you
love right yeah what's the problem
are they
what
we hate people it's so goofy we hate
women
you know how many women listen to Taylor
Swift boo
I don't get it
you know I'll take a tate ad come reach
my audience
no I think she starts her International
tour soon good go let's get out of here
scram
I you know what all right I'll say this
if Travis Kelsey and Taylor Swift
release the sex video I'll consummate
this this uh relationship and be like
fine you guys can have sex you can be
boyfriend girlfriend I don't buy it
until I see some dick in vagina do you
think can you please not speak so vulgar
it's just it's a wild thing to throw I
mean pardon my take though again
it's just not good enough you did say
pardon my take if you're gonna make a
joke here's what I'm
I would love
gracious toward him and think that that
he doesn't truly
have um bad qualities so maybe he's
trying to make the joke like you guys
are shoving this couple down our throats
both of you as a unit man and woman that
that's how they identify equal
opportunity equal opportunity if you're
gonna shove this down our throats I want
to see some action however the way he
said it wasn't funny and it just wasn't
that funny first of all I don't think
they're being shoved down the throes
like in a sense I I empathize with them
like if they're just two people trying
to date like what if what have they done
that's shoving it in their face other
than like she went in a private box to
watch him play and they went to an after
party together like what have they
actually done the show the networks that
are foaming at the mouth about it NFL is
doing you wrong not Taylor they want the
uh they want the ratings man like what
what more by the way thank you someone
got me Aqua for I think I'm saying
Aquaphor that's nice
that will literally uh give you skin
cancer if you put it on a tattoo oh
okay cool by the way so
okay so this has petroleum
or no petrolatum which I I learned is
purified petroleum jelly
so it's
so it's better
that's the only ingredient wait no
mineral oil
and then lanolin alcohol is not lanolin
by the way it's a different thing
because that is an ingredient here
just saying
just saying just saying
what
oh this is thick bruh
wait I'm squeezing it so hard I think
you have to pop the seal open it and
so thick
no no no it's a Twist Off twist off I'm
twisting
really love it pop it
pop off you can do it
is it a pop-off you got it buddy
no this is there's something
there's some funny business going on
here just squeeze super hard look at it
wait it is no it is unpopped dude you
have to squeeze it so hard is it
really cold or something I don't know
like try squeezing this it's like the
hardest squeeze of my life dude
try to give that a squeeze
the baby
I'm a man would you like me to use my
large hands to help you Ethan go ahead
give it a squeeze
I broke the ceiling
yeah right yeah I did I broke the shield
you want to arm wrestle me do you think
you're stronger
um can I have a few days to prep
all the time you need okay cool see you
Friday
um I'm gonna lay some awkward for down
on your desk for your elbow
it won't work it won't mask
it slams his chin down on the table Yeah
easy dub doesn't matter
okay this seems nice
you know
protective layer we love that don't we
we love a protective layer folks this
this is nice
thank you yeah so back to these
criminals who need to be tried for
crimes against humanity uh for their
take here let's continue to listen
I'm saying that right now is she
pregnant p and v I haven't seen her
drinking at these games I started
drinking series
not really drinking some juice yeah
anyone with me should we demand it I
want to see I want to see pnv
it's not funny
nobody meant you already said it dude
yeah you don't need the homies to ride
for this
Let It Go man
I say p p a p a or pnv or pnm yeah
that's good I'll take P I'll even take
uh h on on P
and yeah I'll take a hand job that's
fine give us the Lord you want to see
your homie's is that what you're
saying that's definitely what he's
saying you want to see boys you're
jealous that she's seeing his and
you're not yeah just as I know Travis
was on their podcast like a few months
ago What Judas how dare you go against
the family after you are graciously
you are graced by this uh god-like NFL
player who frankly has an impeccable
record personality he is frankly a
perfect match
for Taylor and you sat across from a man
like that and this is how you treat him
now with such disrespect do you have
that that tweet that you showed me
earlier of his you guys this Travis let
me find it I mean what punishment is
even suitable for this high of a crime
I think we need to invent a new one
capital P I know it's not I know it's
not enough
I know
pull up that Russian chiropractor clip
with the with the ropes here look can
this man do any wrong
Travis this is the he said Grandma
cookies and the love of my parents
hahaha successful night
why would you say anything bad about him
how dare you
oh and by the way the Bears I don't
know I don't know anything I don't I'm
just kidding no I don't know I'm just
I'm just trying to get under his skin
he's just because the Hat no the Bears
might be cool they might be great we
love the Bears what are the Bears
Chicago Bears bro why do you care about
Chicago so my family's from okay
he does he does Chicago Sports yeah well
you do some LA Sports I'm a Dodger
Dodgers fan but balma Bears again and
anything Tom Brady does you catch like
all the Dodger games I used to be better
about it uh post seasonal I usually get
more Investments we'll be in yeah we'll
be all in which is like we got a 100
game win baby
for the Dodgers there it is Zach
who's trying who's angling his way to
get me a guest on part of my take
I have no no desire to be on this show I
think they're completely wrong with four
yeah they suck
oh look I said right no they suck he's
allowed to say that because he's a fan
you're not allowed to say that about the
Bears just just to bring this up because
I did get heat for what I said last week
I think he's completely wrong uh I think
what the Taylor Swift to the NFL is
great for football
it brings a new audience it's exciting
um because it's just a bunch of
dudes with
swinging balls
um so yeah I think it's I think it's
great let me say this introducing women
to our fan base was the best thing that
ever happened to this show wow yeah wow
respect women
expect winning y'all it really was and
so you were so brave for that thank you
and so what are you afraid of I think we
need to get them on a train and say bye
bye
that's all he wants Exile from life
not I don't want to move them I want to
remove them he needs to be banished no
no no no he needs to be removed you're
talking about carrial plane you're
talking about capital punishment yes
talking about him being tried
by a jury of his peers and sentences no
trial right oh no trust to death oh wow
no trial for these I don't know
if that's that's probably still not good
enough
hey here's what we'll do we'll gather
all their ashes and drop it from the
ceiling of a Taylor Swift heiress tour
show yes
the finale along with confetti and all
the balloons it'll just be mixed in with
the confetti guns at the end there you
go you'll be breathed in by Taylor Swift
fans as your final Act
not bad enough still
I just I don't understand why it's so
hated that she's like oh she's he's
gotta be half joking dude like even if
he was half joking he's um he is
Apparently that is a real sentiment
though I I'm not familiar enough with
this podcast I know how sarcastic or not
he's being but uh
it's definitely not a clip you want out
there I mean look at the stats the uh
people watching uh NFL games it's gone
up like it's super Ball numbers it's
insane yeah the the that's what I've
heard it's nuts also moreover again it's
just like to put any of it on I mean she
seems to enjoy going to football games
is she not allowed to do that no sure
you know and ignoring that it's Taylor
Swift ignoring everything else just to
say I need to see a sex tape to believe
that they're dating and then keep
emphasizing that it's just super weird
in general it's so it's so weird and
then you're just like actually and then
in the end actually all I want to do is
see his all right yeah he's like no
I don't want a sex tape I don't I don't
need a a BJ tape all basically I just
want to see his dick that's a an
anonymous hand over it it's kind of uh
go ahead
okay bro he was one step away from
saying Taylor doesn't even have to be
there if I'm being honest she's behind
the camera just my hand yeah yeah my
hands I could swap out with her a week
yeah then I'll believe it
the minute I give him a hand job I'll
believe it when I can give him a
then I believe it people say he's 100
joking I agree he's he's obviously being
silly
but there's got to be some truth to that
that's why I want to put them to
execution without a trial
like there's gotta because we can't let
that truth come out there's got to be
just a sight we gotta silence the truth
all right let's keep let's keep
listening
yeah
give us a Lauren bobert and I'll be like
you know what these two lovebirds they
can't they can't get their hands off
each other it's fine until that happens
I think it's it's fake and I think it's
for clicks and I think Taylor Swift is
using the NFL I think you're doing this
for clicks I think you're using Taytay
to get clicks for your dumb ass show
nobody cares about loser with the Bears
hat idiot
pardon my take but I think you need to
put on a choo-choo train and said
bye-bye
send you to the gulag
what's the uh what's the little dog
sticker in the middle on his uh laptop
that's a Grateful Dead thing in the
middle is it I don't know what the dogs
on the side of it are yeah that's why I
was and like how dare you even conjure
the image of the Grateful Dead for peace
no
like when Bieber said uh Aunt Frank was
a Belieber
she definitely would have been Jerry
wasn't Swifty bro for sure yeah for sure
even worse he wrote it in the journal
and like the diary there's like a guest
login at the at the uh house are you
talking about Biebs yeah and he wrote I
know you would have been a believer
who's to say she wouldn't have been what
a dude I think he was a
kid at the time I don't know how old he
was when he died bad form pretty soon
pretty psycho all right go on then keep
digging your grave
to try to make her star bigger I think
uh I would see some TF did he just say
she's trying to make her star bigger do
you not know that she's the biggest
thing on the planet Earth
like that that that pushes me towards
being he's he's not serious about it yes
he's completely wrong too I mean the
last game she was at had the most views
since the Super Bowl alone and I said
that makes a lot of sense because the
last time I turned football onto the TV
was to see Rihanna at the Super Bowl I
mean if anything that oh so you're
saying you don't watch for Taylor Swift
I'm saying I tuned in again for Taylor
Swift so the numbers matching the stats
line up I thought I had you no but like
what's your theory then ah girl she's
trying to get all the NFL fans to come
to her tour her sold out tour excuse me
How You Gonna sell tickets to a sellout
tour Bears fan let's not bring the
Bears into this
sit your ass down all right you already
are we love Ditka
the NFL is making more money on the back
of Taylor Swift
than they ever did from
other things
that would be funny to say
for sure
using the NFL to try to make her star
bigger I think uh I would see some TF
I would see some teeth
TF titty titty like
titty that's what I'm saying
it's so funny but here's the thing if
you were if you're asking for titty
that's like way
weirder and wilder than the other
suggestions yeah like just the sex tapes
of titty that's just a
weird request bro shame on you man ditch
Steve won't do it
damn man
either way uh good game memes you fought
hard they fought real hard uh and then
we got the Broncos next week so
hopefully the sharing uh back to back a
week together yeah you almost said wins
yo if you guys are mad about me bringing
up the Bears then you need to talk to
him about dropping he needs to be
dropped as a fan because the Bears can
only be judged by the quality of their
fans and so they need to send a letter
they need to send a legal notice or
something to this guy saying that we
disassociate you you are not allowed to
be a fan of the Bears
until then
disavow it is possible he could be a fan
of the TV show The Bear
it's a bear fan I don't believe that's
possible no I don't think it's possible
but anything is possible which is a fair
Counterpoint
back-to-backer games good games oh
Hackett Revenge game yeah oh that's
gonna be awesome that will be awesome
packet Revenge game also means just
perspective just gorgeous dudes talking
about yeah Taylor Swift I want to
see your titties get yeah yeah
the game yo I'd love to see Taylor Swift
get her titties
we're just a couple of dudes talking
about sports
I'd love to see his giant in
somebody's hand damn this is this is
what doesn't matter whose hand turns me
off to like uh sports sports talk it's
so territorial and like if you if
anything has changed it's like oh you're
a sinner you've gone against the family
like it it's so it's so bro culture we
don't buy that yeah I just hope all of
the teams have fun
you know right dude no head injuries
just fun yo where's that I hope
everybody plays a safe game everybody
does their best I don't believe someone
somebody will come out on top but that
doesn't really say anything about who's
best I mean right it's all about the
experience I don't believe someone's a
fan unless I see a sex tape of them
another fan in a jersey
right which would be great PR for the
NFL people saying it's a joke but not a
funny one thank you exactly yeah that's
that's what it seems like dude you just
you just you gotta learn man you're
gonna learn the hard way you don't go
against Taytay and the fam you guys
think it's a joke you don't do it
you think it's a big joke guess what now
your life's ruined
Show's canceled
you've been banished from ever going to
another NFL game banished done the
organization has spoken out against you
the Bears organization has denounced you
as a fan now what
now what do you do shame
shame exactly shame give me a break
shame keep going
yo where's that Panera Bread though
shame oh it's gonna be a minute it's
gonna take a while because it's a pretty
big order damn it's been a while how
long has it been
like an hour that's unacceptable that's
shame maybe not that long I don't know
okay I'm gonna replace the order at 305.
305 a half hour ago yeah but they do but
that's it yeah that's it not that long
yeah but they did give us a warning
saying that because of the size of the
order it's gonna take a while
don't worry the soup will be here
whatever what is it gonna get soggy yeah
what's gonna happen the soup's gonna get
soggy right actually the bread bowl
would definitely get something they
don't do you think they give us the
sauce in the bread bowl oh yeah that's
probably separated
surely sure
Panera knows how to do it I just want a
loaf of bread dude
do you think you get to cut it open
yourself or no no that'd be crazy that'd
be so sick you're not trained you would
want to cut it open yourself yeah why I
don't know it's just authentic you could
rip at it it's like I'm cooking the food
I would probably rip some extra breading
out though you know because sometimes
it's just not clean her up a little bit
there's not enough volume sure yeah in
the bowl
you can put your on the live for
10 bucks I know what that means
tune in Friday or just my b-hole is that
a busy
on the live for 10 bucks too low though
yeah it's gonna cost more than that yo
this is super weird mate
my cursor is like having a seizure
here let me pull this up so you guys can
see
look at this what is that
is that weird
uh the mouse is still plugged in from
the other day with the Counter-Strike
gag it's probably the mouse
thanks that's a throwback sound bite
that is
it honestly might be uh one of the first
well it is it was pretty early uh it was
you never remember we always go through
this first laugh you lose right yes and
it's a dude breaking a world record the
Coconuts no walnuts the one breaking
walnuts with his forehead
it's one of my favorite videos ever but
we can't show it because it always gets
claimed did it really yeah it's because
it's Guinness oh those yep they
claim everything sons of they're
gonna get a Guinness world record for
most claims yeah
[Music]
so I think they're done though it's like
like the the Bears is the measuring bar
for the worst team yeah they're they're
done but he was so confident in this
that he posted this clip on Twitter he
did not yeah with the caption uh if
Taylor Swift is going to be taking over
our Sundays I'm going to need to see a
sex tape these are my demands you did
not post that to Twitter you literally
just dug your own grave and put a bullet
in to Swifty's hands and gave them a gun
and said end it you lunatic
uh here's the Tweet he posted
cutie Cinderella ratioed him Queen she's
a Swifty I know that
she said
the floodgates are opening he said if
Taylor Swift is going to be taking over
Sundays I'm gonna need a sex tape these
are my demands
cutie Cinderella Jesus Christ what an
absolute piece of you are ratioed
let's go imma go hit that with a leg
you're a piece of do you think he
realized he'd made a a great mistake he
didn't erase it though so no he you're
getting a lot of attention from this
yeah he kind of doubled down even in
some of the comments someone asked him
straight up do you regret posting this
he said no well I guess in their in
their case it's because it's just Bros
so the Bros are down with all that yeah
yeah I want to see her get titty
he's so right bro
I love titty videos
[Laughter]
uh
oh and Ludwig's in here defending his
girl have you watched one episode of the
yard like what are we talking about oh
he's saying oh well your boyfriend is
saying
the that's supposed to mean let's
follow this thread
okay they're done careful yeah it
doesn't go anywhere
um
um cats was mad because moments before
the game
they had a voice ad which we we
explained a voice ad
The Voice the show yeah she's on that
show
um I think they're doing covers of
Taylor Swift she's too big to go on that
show yeah I think they're doing covers
of her songs I'm not exactly sure let me
if I was her manager I would say no no
no no we're not going on The Voice
that's for like how that's for you know
not for you girl
uh the NFL's increased its popularity
since Swift has been showing up to games
which you saw Kelsey and the Chiefs beat
the Jets 70.
27 million viewers tuned on
compared to an average of 24 million who
watched Swift cheer on her new boo
is that how you spell boo
b-e-a-u I've always
there's also Bay it all means boyfriend
girlfriend partner bo boy is that a name
it's also anemia we have made a grave
mistake Taylor Swift has been on The
Voice not recently though probably not
recently when's the last time she was on
The Voice season 17 I don't know what
year
well if she did go on it was probably
because she's just being really cool and
doing them a huge favor doing on a
massive face but we you know what we are
looking forward to is dancing Star
Dancing with the Stars Taylor Swift
Edition night which is coming soon yeah
we're looking forward to that oh we're
all let me mark it on my calendar right
now Dana can you remind me
thank you I will
yeah but um
data from NBC also suggests the ratings
peaked and an estimated 29.4 million
making Jets Chiefs the most watched
contest since February Super Bowl game
also Kelsey's jersey sales have gone up
too I wonder if he gets a cut of that
how does that work with the jersey sales
probably probably not
because they just pay them a SAT they
just pay him a fat salary maybe not
though
uh 2019 she's on the voice that was her
return she was originally there in 2014.
uh actually the NFL players union uh
contract says that the players get
two-thirds of the money by selling
jerseys I mean it's their name
on it they should dude he's gonna dude
he's gonna make a bajillion dollars
that's crazy
holy smokes
yeah well if you ask me it's still a
little bit capitalist Pig because when I
put your guyses on March you get a
hundred percent
oh so true the trading card 100 you
understand you're free I'm not like them
oh God look at my arms fat jiggle
look at my fat
and I just think Dan's asking if his
camera's stuttering I just think it
looks unnatural do you see this that
wasn't what I was talking about I know
I'm kidding why does it look like that
because you lost a lot of weight
recently you think my arms were that fat
yeah
I mean really what other explain we're
doing the oh my God that looks so
weird are you posing the theory
that those are not your arms
the shirt makes it look crazier I don't
think that's too crazy it makes sense I
don't yeah I think you might be feeling
dysmorphic right now huh Dan was
laughing at me yeah no it looks well the
way you're moving is crazy wait hold on
let me try that again
just hold hold it like this
do that
yeah that looks normal yeah
damn he's built
built different literally look at this
it's just from it's just you you've lost
a lot of weight over the last six months
hold on
this is the new arm thing
oh boy
I don't know why this arm this arm
specifically looks so crazy
there you go
bro
that's amazing
give me the egg man it's like two ball
sacks he'll give you the heck it's
giving me that
can I dump my body
can you what can I dump my body dump it
like because I got the ick
I need a new got him
um someone in chat said Nano arms yeah
totally that's what my grandma's arms
used to look like just like that it's
crazy
it's just I think it's
your perception of yourself too okay
show it again what's true
right
it's loose skin like I said let me see
your arm
I didn't recently lose a lot of weight I
just want to see jiggle it oh you're
sure just holding it tight though it's
not loose well I'm take your shirt off
no I'm kidding
[Music]
oh why
that's hot though
bump that bump that
[Music]
someone said he needs a scrotox your
arms
oh yeah
I'm a big balls
put your balls in my mouth
All Right Moving On
Long Live Taylor Swift
and may her enemies perish and help fire
uh Portnoy got involved though brother
yeah he claims to be a Swifty yeah right
I don't buy that for a second
um
um thank you for this I guess here's the
Tweet he's referring to listen I am
repulsed by Barstool
big cat as the next person but Barstool
Presidente is the biggest Swifty on the
planet you may not like Barstool but
over overall there Taylor Swift shop
it's unfaint unfair to paint the entire
company
Dave said Thank you Taylor Swift
I literally lost sleep over Dan's
grotesque comments but we do live in a
free country and I believe in freedom of
speech hopefully Dan can learn from this
and we can all move on Tailor's about
love not hate I'm sensing sarcasm
and I'm not appreciating the sarcasm
this is a serious issue shame on
him yet again not taking things
seriously scumbag
why don't you go talk about with your
teenage friends you have a podcast on
yeah and people are calling them out and
saying it's hypocritical because they
even sell merch that has Taylor Swift's
name on it in their store oh they should
be sued
wait how can I do that here's one of
them right here number or letter d just
facetiously like it's just a reference
to her
it just says I saw the picture of it
just says Swifty in a really weird font
this is a few of there's a few uh
or at least still Swifty it says Phil
Swifty
I think it's a play on that maybe but
they do have a few other ones that say
they even mention her name let me see
if it looks like this
I don't think that's I don't think
they're confusing anyone I think it's a
reference to this is that Phil Swift I
was wondering who that is
yeah all right well Phil Put The Knife
Down Jesus
I sent another one
here's the other one let's see
all right this one is official bar stool
merch
it says
if you're ever
gonna be uh the fans are standing up for
Dave they're saying no he legitimately
is a hardcore Taylor Swift fan he talks
about her all the time apparently this
is a real shirt they sell
I'm on their website that's a Taylor
Swift lyric all you're ever gonna be is
mean and a liar empathetic
um and they do not I doubt they have the
license to sell this you guys
we need to file a complaint with the FCC
or something mods
that song is good
what are the mods doing about this
Dave porkboy thank you for your uh
commentary I don't buy it though
people are saying the Swifty thing is a
play on a there's a player with the last
names uh Swift however I uh I just
choose to accept it's the flex tape guy
because that's that's funny it's Phil
Swift
so here's some nuclear takes I guess
from Twitter let's see
this guy represents barcel Sports I hope
they crumble disgusting barbaric
outright ignorance who has zero respect
for women why does he still have a job
if Barstool doesn't agree with this type
of rhetoric good question
pull up the Russian why are they going
so easy on him I don't understand
like I'm going way harder hello you just
want him to lose his job I had to lose
everything
do you know what I mean are you are you
even a real fan
did you pull it thank you this is what I
want to happen to him
everyone in that room needs to go
through this
[Music]
okay
that's it
[Music]
Russian chiropractor
you know what this is probably
laughs
one's a lie in the air
you know this is probably not as crazy
as just hitting them in the back with a
mallet I feel like there's probably more
medicinal I don't know pulling the arms
trying to draw and quarter them
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's like miscalculated at all that
would kill you rip your arms off well no
they they're right on man I mean they
did it if one of them dropped slow that
would have been such a disaster
[Music]
laughs
that's you okay so watch it here you
know what happens people that go against
the Swifty family
oh let me guess
[Music]
[Laughter]
nothing
I'll say no more
oh yeah I was reading the nuclear takes
these are pretty fun let's see
one more time
I'm way over 18.
you remember you used to answer that and
be like ah just turned 18 I'm over 18.
I'm way over 18 man
20 years over 18. that's old
give or take
it going
[Music]
[Applause]
and you can come home
[Music]
everything is gonna be all right
[Applause]
dude it's crazy
oh man looks fun it's so fun
well you gotta be using
all right so this guy's going easy on
him let's see
please stay away from schools
don't be staying away from all buildings
if I had my way right
if I grew up and saw a clip of my father
saying this I'd kill myself okay Jesus
all right come on now settle down
banking
a slot for banks
bring back Jesus all right I did kind of
say something similar to that but
this may or may not be ironic
well this happened a long time ago
yeah but I'm saying it I know that it's
real baby that's not what I'm saying
what happened he gets decapitated not
hung
or hanged which is probably a more
humane way to kill someone frankly
uh if it's one swipe well if it's
lightsabers they call it hanging
you need to be on a watch list for this
not gonna lie that that's fair
irresponsive yeah that makes sense
that's fair enough podcasts for you Dan
cats now let's get you behind those bars
okay go to jail they're just saying jail
again going really easy on him jail is
not enough yeah
maybe hard to labor I mean at least
minimum minimum I miss the times when
men would go to war and die
that's pretty funny I love that one it's
a that's an interesting comment
actually
the thoughts provoking to be sure
I missed the times men would go to war
and die it's my fave copy mom
uh interesting
uh there it is
Travis says the NFL is overdoing the
Taylor Swift coverage a bit he did this
is yeah we just wait what is the NFL
doing the NFL overdue
what it what are they doing well during
the broadcast they're like they're doing
like Taylor check-ins so it's them it's
not even her that's what I was saying
earlier is like none of this is on her
she's in a private box she didn't even
asked to be on the TV right she doesn't
need coverage is the NFL overdoing it
what is your honest opinion
he's so dreamy
yeah
beautiful smile too really nice teeth uh
celebrities at games I think it's fun
when they show uh who all is at the game
you know I think uh I think it brings a
little bit more to the atmosphere brings
a little bit more to to what you're
watching
um but at the same time I think uh
they're overdoing it they're they're
overdoing it a little bit for sure
especially my situation right I think
they're they're just trying to have fun
with it and um a lot of uh a lot of the
people I think he's right I think
everyone's just having a good time with
it I mean it's only been two games right
it's not like this is maybe a couple
months from now when we're doing if
they're missing a play yeah every 15
minutes we're doing like a check-in or
whatever then yeah maybe that's it's
getting a little old
not specific to her man he's so dreamy
how tall is he six five
I mean probably he's an NFL player so
probably
pretty tall you could toss me like a
football probably six foot perfect
six foot perfect six foot I hate that
I've never heard that and I hate it so
much six five six five is that six five
six foot better that's Zach's height or
do you just say that against anything
that's just oh I'm apologizing that just
means anyone who's tall just no Travis
is six foot perfect he's six is that a
saying no I just I mean maybe I thought
I created it okay then I then then
you're good I thought that was a thing
that girls did oh I'm I've never heard
he's six foot perfect but I think he's
six foot perfect okay then then I'll let
him I'll let it I allow it thank you
sorry that's I I thought it was the
girls chatting no girl never
you can be under six foot and still foot
can you put five foot perfect you can be
five foot perfect you kidding I'm five
foot perfect okay
what about four what about
you could be a five four man
oh who slits his wrists right five four
perfect
I mean
five foot three perfect
but if you're five foot perfect
go ahead let's hear it I just think the
NFL is not used to celebrities coming to
the games like basketball hasn't figured
out they're all Courtside they're
sitting there they show them once or
twice and then and then they but they
get back to the game the NFL is like oh
look at all these A-list celebrities in
the game keep showing them show them
show them dude listen you show them once
let them know they're there maybe after
a touchdown you get a little clip of it
you can't you can't be overboard with it
people are there to watch the game right
they know what they're doing they know
the swifties are watching they're giving
them what they need what they want what
they desire what they deserve they
deserve yeah yeah
wow this is quite a story just keeps
going man I can't stop talking about
the NFL this from comes from pop base
uh breaking the NFL response to Travis
Kelsey's comments that they're overdoing
it Taylor Swift is this for real is this
real and a new statement to people
the Taylor Swift and Travis Kelsey news
has been a pop culture moment we've
learned leaned into
in real time as it's an intersection of
sports and entertainment
and we see an incredible amount of
positivity around the sport the vast
majority of our content has remained
focused on the game on our players and
the variety of other initiatives I'm
with you you know what I think he's
trying he's doing a little fence sitting
they're trying to appeal to the hardcore
dudes were like I don't want to
see her during my game right
but also being like you know it's not
that serious right
yeah his pushback was pretty mild
um
a little harder he should have defended
her harder but we'll look we'll give him
a pass to this one time
this is his one
this is one chance that's it that's all
I have to say about that well the NFL
and they're probably really leaning into
it because they desperately need some
good PR after the last I don't know 10
years but uh with all the well just the
fact that their sport like uh business
brain damages everybody who plays it
damn it that all of the owners like it's
it's this kind of just like they have
like a Plantation uh the Colin
Kaepernick stuff yeah yeah also one
related ball that one time the fact that
the and I can only say this because uh
cam is not here but the the Patriots
stole the Super Bowl well hold on here
hold on hold on here they were deflated
the ball I don't know anything about it
that's mostly and I know cam is actually
still watching so um Cameron he's about
to message me very angrily right now
Cameron you and I both know that's
horseshit wait weren't they like
proven to be cheater no they were ruled
by an official I've cheated nope I think
maybe they were clear I I don't know I
don't know
anything to be honest I was surprised
that Tom Brady because he doesn't need
to cheat that seems like
maybe he didn't know he must have not
known right
I don't know if he was a
directly implications dude people are so
passionate about this I don't even wanna
Tom Brady well I mean he was the
quarterback so to some degree he was
involved yeah I played the fifth Harry
your honor well who's gonna be in charge
of the who's gonna care if the ball's
deflated if not the quarterback
you know what I mean
I talked to Cameron all we know is that
he makes out with his son that's awesome
we do know that he makes out with his
son repeat he's a loving father which
may be the source of his greatness he's
a loving father look at garyvee he sucks
the life force from his son's leg oh
Cam's type uh here it comes so you
start with flaky I knew
I knew that would set him off well hold
on blade gate deflate gate deflate so
what's the verdict then like the
official verdict
uh deflate gate oh Olivia already sent a
little
11 of the 12 footballs used by the
Patriots offense in the game were under
inflated by at least two pounds each
that information was ultimately proven
to be false and Aquarium was eventually
made in the initial report there you go
poor oh everywhere tonight
yeah they did everything right and they
indicted them it's not fair
but they got through it because uh the
the Pats are the greatest football
franchise of all time Tom Brady Tom
Brady got he got best well he got
suspended for this four game suspension
for cheese
one million fine for the team and a four
game suspension for Patriots quarterback
Tom Brady who cheated
he was docked draft selections and rules
changed because of cheater this the
Wikipedia page on deflategate is so long
like this was such a saga
yeah I just want the longer whoa you're
not kidding look at the they got it yeah
it's like a whole thing wow
what the look at all these sources cited
it's 151 sources I mean it was a big
deal at the time I remember and then I
think a little bit after this Bob Craft
the owner got caught going in like
getting a rub and tug yeah one of these
[Music]
he was caught in a sting operation for
human trafficking
in a sting operation they were they were
investigating this rub and tug massage
place and the girls were being sex
trafficked in Jupiter Florida bro uh cam
says Roger Goodell is a spiteful piece
of is why he was suspended
well Hey listen I don't make the rules I
just read them okay I mean I do see that
the Patriots were penalized by the NFL
let me put up that's what I'm saying
they got penalized
Bob Craft Bob Craft got penisless
this story is really really quite good
he dodged charges of course he did there
was like tape of it too of him getting a
oh God Robert discharges from
prostitution stink oh yeah it was called
The Orchids of Asia oh no the place
he probably didn't know the man is a
billionaire and he goes to this
rubbing tug place in Jupiter
Florida in a strip mall
yeah wow I mean this this is basically
like we sex traffic women the orchids of
Asia that's crazy that's crazy that's a
crazy name man
I can't believe it Dodge charges like
what what kind of place would be like we
all of our massage uh therapists are of
Asian women they're all Asian women I
mean a lot of them just in the title of
the shop you know Cam's uh camsa set
he's like I gotta stop listening him
says he's gonna stop listening he's too
fired up I'm sorry Kim I was just
trolling you
I don't I don't have a strong opinion
about deflategate one way or the other
orchids of Asia was it Day Spa when was
a notorious brothel oh and a family
shopping center what the
how rich guys from a local Country Club
lined up to receive sex acts throughout
the day until the place closed around
midnight
holy crap he used to roll up in his like
Bentley and go get a tuggie in
there good deal good value probably yeah
that shows you how that can just be
happening right in front of you that's
what I asked Fusion he's like it's
everywhere yeah it's like and apparently
you can tell somehow I guess from the
title orchids of Asia yeah you were just
saying that right Russian roses
foreign
I mean what the
all right
well there it is
and there it is actually I don't know if
they were if there was sex trafficking I
I don't want to speak at a turn I don't
know if that was one of the things
I don't want to put that out there if
it's not true
it says a big difference
you know it is called orchids of Asia
though
do the math do your own research and do
your own research people uh but where's
my bread bowl man bro I'm
starving I'm about to
[Music]
I have bad news it says it's not on the
way yet oh they are still preparing it
we hate Panera Bread here does it take
to scoop some soup
they suck I mean it's quality food you
guys it's not like fat it's not Taco
what are they making the soup after our
order
they're growing the uh the veggie the
veggies right they grow in the carrots
oh it's on the way
right now it's on the way they hurt us
they're listening
the ETA
4 30. oh my but I think it's going to
take a little longer than that because I
looked it up and it's I think it's at a
30 minute drive to get to us the soup's
gonna be ice cold dude I don't even care
if it's freshly made I just bro just
defrost my soup and I'll drink it put it
in the microwave yeah I don't give it
over here yeah just I know y'all don't
cook that fresh yeah comes in a bag
yeah plastic bag I know how it is
comes in waves man
um
what is this photo why did why did Cam
send this oh he's getting his arms oh
he's getting the X-ray yeah he's
checking on it for those wondering the
fracture on his elbow
there he is there he is in case you were
wondering was hope he's okay
that must have hurt real bad in that
spot that looks like a probably one of
the most painful spots yeah in the human
body should he have his phone out right
now
yeah
why there's not a thing like you're not
supposed to have like Electronics from
Boston x-ray machine you're thinking of
it MRI MRI oh no I'm pretty sure
actually well yeah I probably don't want
to shoot your phone directly yo Beau
Black's just give us a big what's up
we were but we're gonna watch some
little Tay content but he said watch out
little Tay or someone representing her
is claiming videos showing any clips of
her music video
Bobby
sucker for green
little Tay
don't try oh come on Bobby that's not
polite
all right then I'll then I'll I won't
talk about it you know what I mean
one thing that we were talking about
today there's enough tag there's enough
today we got two taytays hey Dave
Gideon turns to God
I'm fascinated by this one too yeah
so
witty in by the way whittian let me just
say that up front thank you
I need a Saudi to hold me over
cheers my dude
come on man these were working people
were hungry you can't take long bring
the photo I mean it's it's it's it's not
right it's up quite honestly
it's not right
this would we're paying a premium for
Panera Bread too did you did you do the
uh priority delivery option Lena
Lena did you do priority delivery
she said yes yes good move
always thank you so much
all right so jadian
lady and we've talked about him a lot of
times on the show
I'm sure y'all most of you guys know who
he is he's uh was banned on Twitch I
forget why and now he's streaming on
Rumble
you know why he was banned on Twitch
wasn't it Pokey oh
I think it was the pokemane harassment
okay because they made up afterwards
yeah he did make up with Pokeman they
they came to a nice resolution to all of
that but yeah uh he was permanently
banned from twitch after he urged his
fans to harass fellow streamer Pokemon
we launched a hate break he raided her
yeah it was a raid thing and then was
gnarly yeah that's bad that's like the
number one thing not to do right yep
they don't like when you do that
yeah they they made amends uh after a
while okay so now he's on uh Rumble
which as everybody knows is where all
the best creators uh come together for
the best reasons yeah
he put out a video
on September 22nd which is 9 11 squared
911 times two it's z11.
my birthday on his channel what it's my
birthday September 22. yeah dude
he also has 11. he streams on YouTube as
well
yeah I was seeing his streams on YouTube
so he probably splits his time
um so he says on the September 22 uh
live he details a story that he credits
as the Catalyst for his new Devotion to
Christ let's take a listen
now the question we have is is he
trolling or not because after this all
of his live streams are him just doing
Bible studies
yeah yeah my initial when I just heard
about this I was because he does pranks
and stuff I was like oh it's he's a good
thing yeah he's goofing or whatever but
then I saw the volume of content that
he's done like this and I'm
questioning now I have an interesting
theory that I think might be might be
interesting but let's watch it okay
actions you feel me I was with my girl
we were ubering back from her college
and then right when we got back to the
crib the Uber driver she looked back at
us and she asked us a question my aunt
me answering it made my heart sunk but
she asked she said if you guys were to
die right now would you go to heaven or
would you go to hell my Uber driver
asked me that I'd be like whatever bro
one star bye
my Uber driver asked me if I'm going to
heaven or hell
I said no conversation
well you can do that there is yes
or just like a preference yeah you're
going to heaven or hell no talking I
feel like it's such a dick move though
to put no conversation well then you can
have people asking you like this
and giving it existential crisis but now
he's got the story man
I want to uh suggest something because
I'm already seeing a lot of disagreement
in our chat about if he's trolling or
not so I want to do a poll now before we
watch all good idea and see what people
think and then after we review
everything good idea is Gideon trolling
with uh this yes you guys go ahead and
vote I'm gonna play the video
no
he is I had to be honest with myself I
like I had to look into myself I was
like the way I'm living if someone asked
me that I would think I was about to die
it's like I'm in danger Reaper like are
you going to heaven you're gonna kill me
I'd be like what the why are you
asking me am I about to die it's like
a country Pearl yeah exactly
okay all right flip a college and then
right when we got back to the crib the
Uber driver she looked back at us and
she asked us a question my aunt me
answering it made my heart sunk but she
asked she said if you guys were to die
right now would you go to heaven or
would you go to hell I had to be honest
with myself I like had to look into
myself and I was like the way I'm living
right now if God was to take my breath
away right now I'm going to hell I
couldn't even lie bro don't be so hard
on yourself man see that's I
don't like that all the hell it's
such bull crap man bull Huey
steaming pile of bull Huey
it's like you're just a normal guy
you're not going to hell
and if there is a hell that God's gonna
send you there then then you know
him
he's dumb
it's a vain dumb idiot
I about in chat you feel me like and you
know what's crazy chat I'll be letting
so many worldly things dictate how my
day's gonna go you feel me you got
people out here that are battling cancer
uh having horrible like you know being
victims of horrible crimes and all kinds
of stuff right and they still have the
ability to put a smile on their face and
be genuinely happy I get a strike on my
channel and I'm not able to post for a
week I'm over here in the slumps you
would have thought you would have
thought my dog died chat the way I was
around here acting when I was gone for
that week bro just pouting being moody
being rude to people the only reason why
I was acting like that is because I'm
letting
worldly things
he doesn't seem to be joking at all
he seems to be uh doing seems very uh
yeah self-aware and yeah reflective
because I don't think he would invoke
some of these things if he was kidding
like there's people dying of cancer and
all this like that's not that's not
funny to joke about right I watched some
of his lives yesterday when I was
looking into this and I guess over a
year ago he was talking on impulsives
podcast about how he wants to find God
and be more religious he was talking
about with George the previous co-hosts
on impulsive and George actually uh came
on Gideon's live and they talked about
it as well
so by the way interesting to note the
majority think he's trolling 56 say he's
trolling at this moment yeah pretty
sharply divided though like yeah pretty
close poll
um and to add on to that just one more
thing uh he said he's not gonna be
putting out the same type of content and
he was going to release that EDP uh
video but because he's not doing that
anymore he doesn't want to put on his
channel so his fans were like oh what
the hell we want to see it but he said
they're going to put on the other guy's
Channel I'm sorry I forget his name oh I
forgot where is that I'm waiting for
that it's coming soon but it is going to
come out just not on Jillian's Channel
hmm dude something happened with EDP
that's what happened this man found God
he's awesome he was Disturbed yeah
he seems genuine to me right now though
how my spirit is and like you know the
Bible talks about it all the time you
know you you can't be moved by the world
you have to hate the world chat like
it's crazy like Jesus is telling me that
I have to hate the world but the world
loves me you feel me right and that's
like a honest predicament that I
he said
he said Jesus thought I was telling him
to hate the world
I must have missed that uh then play me
and that's like a honest predicament
that I World Loves Me Like Jesus is
telling me that I have to hate the world
but the world loves me you feel me and
that's like a honest predicament that I
thought I was in I I just don't know
what he means like well I hate it's
probably not the right word for it but
it's
he's talking about uh
to not concern yourself with worldly
things in in this world to dedicate
yourself to the kingdom of God
God hates the world it's not that
or Jesus hates the world
I never heard that interpretation yeah
no
okay
so anyway that's enough of that I mean
we've seen he's being he's being very
sincere in my opinion
so
talks about
uh how his life
excuse me
has been preoccupied with worldly things
is this this is the same clip right
yeah it's the same Gideon was about to
take a gambling deal with my bookie that
he uh turned down
foreign
on the top of my head I don't know of
I've never seen him do it but I think uh
the next verse that's how it is with the
one who stores up treasure for himself
and is not rich towards God and bro
that's literally what I would have been
doing if I took that gambling deal chat
I would be storing up for myself instead
of God I would be storing up like I was
trying to make it seem like oh for you
guys just do more giveaways or my
parents but no it was my own selfish
needs bro I don't need any more money
I really don't even smoke
okay that didn't strike me as Super
genuine that transition I think that's
just an unfortunate he hasn't had time
for rebranding yeah he hasn't rebranded
the end card yet I just want to smoke
weed and I don't like God
Jesus is a loser
I could have not
so since this announcement
all of his videos and live streams have
been related to him
finding God now let's take a list let's
take a look right and this is what kind
of tipped me towards it not being a
troll because if it is you are keeping
this up for a really long time my guy so
he has not put out any content other
than this bible stuff right at least on
his this on his channel yeah okay
this is on so there's some things to
consider why does he have the O.J
Simpson subscriber or else up that
doesn't seem crazy he's rebranded OJ's
praying why wouldn't he change that to a
Jesus thing
change the banner why do what O.J
Simpson's threatening to kill me in my
life it's on it's on the list it's on
the list it's on the to-do list yeah
okay
and then what do you think about this
thumbnail it's like the Bible and the
big smile and the thumbs up
it's like
it seems a little trolley but then I
mean he's on here for a long period of
time and I was scrubbing through and
he's
reading the Bible discussing it yeah
they're all really long like hour and a
half yeah so hours now every day he's
streaming for hours uh trolling about
believing in gotta I don't really think
so I think people are watching too it's
kind of interesting like 60 000 I mean
that's a lot for a Bible study here let
me show you an example this one is
called dust my return to Christ offend
thee repent with chill stream
I sent an example of a good one I think
where he's reacting to this clip of
speed and he said that he related to
this clip so much
yeah what and then like what is this
he plays this at the beginning of all of
them and this is why I say rumble
because he has this big Rumble thing
here sure yeah it's like him in The Sims
reading a Bible it looks looks like a
joke doesn't it
was that looks like maybe it was some AI
art that he just made or something I
don't know something weird about it hold
on let me look at this clip you sent uh
Maybe
the clip go
thank you
are you a Christian
am I a Christian okay see that's a
little very you know great question you
know what I'm saying but let me ask you
this I don't know answer the question
first it's a great question because a
Christian is someone that's repented of
their sins that doesn't support sexual
immorality that's not I'm sorry these
people are so full of it
they're all such arrogant pricks
like they are just so judgmental that's
why they do it so they can judge
everyone around them for not being as
devote as them
such a Croc it's so annoying especially
when you look at the mall like
dude I don't want to hear I'm going to
hell I'm just trying to buy some
sneakers right
just trying to get my my uh Jays yeah
damn
walking for fame but living for Jesus
someone who's denied themselves I'm not
like I don't hate really I don't if
you're religious I I understand that
perspective I just don't like the people
who are like
Ugg so aggressive and judgmental like
this guy as being it's like
come on mind your own business
bro these words felt like it was like
being spoken to me man bro God uses Us
in so many different ways God was using
not only David Lane here but speed and
like bro looking looking like look in
the speeds eyes bro you can like
literally see you can see the inner
conflict in his eyes
you know what I mean and I don't mean
this at all to demonize him because when
I seen this like it had me scared too
because I was looking at myself bro the
stuff I do like you know it's probably
it's worse than what speed be doing in
all honesty so like I was really looking
at myself here's chat and it's crazy not
against you trying to make money okay
but
if you're a Christian you need to repent
of your sins otherwise just like any
person here not just you
no the guy keeps cutting him off dude
he's being in Hell of annoying
how old is how old is he 18 it's like
it's like it's like it's like it's like
it's like it's like
it's like
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
it's time to get canceled
hahaha
[Music]
all right
what happened once it comes back it's
still going to take 20 seconds
oh wait no people are hearing this now
right that's how the button Works hello
uh yeah our main um switching computer
just randomly decided to freeze but with
the way the system is now
I was able to use the button as a tech
difficulty screen so uh I hope you
enjoyed those we've got a ton that have
been submitted uh on the subreddit and I
think a lot of them you guys have
probably never even seen before so
hope you enjoyed the show never in the
bathroom right now by the way that was
divine intervention because we took the
lord's name in vain and then immediately
we went down he struck us down
y'all better repent with us I'm
repenting I I Repent my sins to Jesus
and uh what was the other thing oh yeah
and I don't
approve of uh sexually immoral things
all right slay stop it thank you stop it
no no titty
I put some on and got him on his knees
and I began to stop into him from behind
I wanted to like move my car and I come
back to just everything not working I
was super confused and I was like what
happened
oops we're back Ethan
uh somebody asked are you ever gonna
play Counter-Strike two with the crew on
see you next Tuesday uh
Maybe
I guess we could do that sometime that'd
be fun it would be actually be fun we we
all usually work during that time yeah
we've got like show plans lately I've
just been closely watching and panicking
yeah it's supposed to be our day where
we get work done and then Ethan just
stresses I'm just like locked in on the
show
so yeah
um make a pledge for Jesus and hit your
women Bill Burr that's a billboard quote
make a pledge for Jesus and hit your
women yeah well hold on what's a good
sign because I was kind of smack talking
God that's what we were joking about
yeah we were struck down but on the
other hand you know kind of a light
touch more of a slight slap yeah there
is yeah it's just letting you know
I'm watching he's the most merciful
speaking of God's angels
what's a Panera here alfredo
he's so perfect he's been having a hard
time I think
he's having a hard time yeah
oh really he's just really anxious
because he doesn't he's like who do I
have to wrestle with who do I have to
boss me around
he just took every Shredder just told
him yeah kind of yeah
you know and now he's he's happy to like
learn to make decisions for himself oh
no oh poor guy poor Alfredo yeah oh God
he's so cute he's getting there though
he's getting I got some super cute
photos that I was planning on posting
after the show of of Freddy yeah
[Music]
all right so let's see what's happening
we were talking about wedding yeah yeah
they were now at all I'm in Manchester
right now you're asking me questions
about God okay you know I love God you
know but just just
okay okay okay let me it is
stop talking to me sir have a nice day
Chad like that wasn't even that wasn't
even really
speak that was like his inner demons in
him we all have inner demons with us bro
whenever like the word of God is
prophesized and you're talking about
Jesus Christ and everything here your
your demons and stuff they just get
agitated it's crazy like you literally
basically okay so that's that and now
let's watch this live here
you know
there's people watching though man
people are getting down with God there's
a lot of people yeah it's crazy
let's go to the comments they're all
like
Gideon you have started my spiritual
journey at 14 years old started reading
the Bible and it's going good bro you
inspired me the real ones aren't mad at
you but more impressed you owe it to
yourself to devote your energy to
something greater we're all happy for
you
he is a real one for this you can see
the Holy Spirit working in him
and while and he's a different person
now God bless Jillian it's all like
very serious we're not under the law but
under grace I don't even know what what
you know
so weird
let me skip forward
I got it in cash got it in cash so yeah
I like when he has the Bible you will
keep my commands
you know what here we're going to
um the NSB so we can kind of get that
we'll kind of get that uh New Testament
feel but if you love me you will keep my
Commandments
[Music]
and this is Christ talking let me turn
that red letter on let me turn that red
letter on
my brother man I hope your Shabbat was
blessed and well as well brother man and
um I hope you have a great Shabbat next
week or this week
James 2 24. you still need to live
accordingly to his word we cannot simply
rely on the fact that he died for us
facts facts facts facts now there's two
in Romans 3 talk about this uh I forget
which one's which but if I'm not
mistaken I think Romans 2 is about Jews
who were like yo we already go on that
could be a song by keep going it's about
Jews who did what keep the law why do we
need to believe in Christ and then Paul
breaks down you have to believe in
Christ because he's the justifier for us
if you won't believe in Christ then you
can't enter into the kingdom and then in
Romans 3 I believe it talks about people
being like well if we have faith why do
we even need to keep the law because uh
Faith May abound and then uh Paul says
at the end of uh Romans 3 here let me
the truth cartel
brother God bless you I would love to
talk about the gospel and walk in the
water find that real quick
Romans 3
uh I think it's this last verse yeah
here
he's pretty slick with those references
man he's all over James Jen Rome uh
Roman I don't know right here right here
since indeed God who will justify the
circumcised by faith and the uncircum
uncircumcised through faith is one what
since wait what God will justify the
circumcised
by faith
and the uncircumcised
through faith
I don't these a lot of this stuff is
like
you really have to try to extract yeah I
get nothing from but I love the I love
using circumcised uncircumcised as an
analogy for anything
yeah it's pretty poetic it's pretty fun
flowery language
we do we then nullify the law through
faith so do we get rid of the law
through faith may it never be on the
contrary we established the law so let's
see what establish
um
this man is this man is serious I don't
if this is the troll I don't know where
what it is he's a world-class actor if
he's trolling is kind of what I think so
my my only Theory plausible theory is
that
he's doing this to stick it to rumble or
something because you know when you're a
streamer you have to all you have to
fulfill a certain amount of hours to get
paid
and so the only thing I could think is
like I'm gonna do the hours but you
I'm gonna do it so that nobody cares and
nobody watches and he's gonna do this
Bible study thing but I don't sense any
irony
you know
this man is serious
yeah I I have the same thoughts like I
was surprised him talking about demons
and everything and also he's saying
stuff like uh
you know talking about speed he's
potentially creating problems for
himself uh but it's because of his faith
he believes it so
the last poll was about 50 50. it was
actually it was 56 percent he is
trolling so majority
now it's looking more like 70 I just
went to 67 but
it seems a lot of people have uh flipped
wow
so this is this is real interesting this
man has given it all up for God
he's giving it all up so yeah this pull
is circumcised whereas the one blessed
pole is uncircumcised something
no way he knows that much if he's
trolling yeah dude he was zipping around
that Bible like nothing dude sure
talking about Paul
you know the Romans the Romans the Jews
once again a man thinking about Rome I
just can't get over that like they just
read one book it's like there's there's
a so many it's a big book like but
there's so many books and things in the
world but they just they're like I just
with this one book I just love this
book I'm gonna read it over and over and
over and over I've read that book I've
read it yeah read it again the Bible is
Gideon's Roman Empire I would say at
least he is reading the book because
kind of he's doing like Cliff Notes
he's just doing like weird Commandments
well most people don't
read the Bible
hold on since when can you abridge God's
word well maybe like once in your life
you go from front to back but at you
know
then you skip Around The Abridged
version well how much is there to think
about like genuinely there's a lot going
on it's a big bug I'm trying to
understand each verse a big book
yeah and that's the thing too and then I
mean you saw he was on some website that
has all the different versions because
you know there's like a million
different translations of the Bible that
all vary slightly and so like you
compare between them but people have
been doing this like I feel like we've
done it there's like there's been a lot
of analysis
you know that's like the whole their
whole thing is like we're gonna read the
Bible we're gonna read it again and then
we're gonna read it again
and they've read it again so many times
and they've come together and said this
is what the Bible means and then they've
come together and said this is what the
Bible means based on that group but
people are still trying to they we don't
need more to the conversation I think it
holds the book two thousand years I
think it offers a sense of hope for
people
I think he might have been feeling lost
and yeah there's this one thing this one
book but it everyone turns to it as this
sign of Hope
I think that's what he's trying to do
with it sure
sure I'm being a little facetious silly
about it but
obvious yeah people turn to religion
when they uh are in times of need
and um I'll ask you this question Zach
if you died right now would you go to
heaven or hell
the hell dude yeah my man
I pray there's a uh you just don't
believe in Hell exactly if there's a
hell below we'll all gonna go in the
words of
Curtis Mayfield
it was a religious guy I think that's so
insane to me that you guys don't believe
in hell I'm so jealous I'm so jealous
literally that's all we're told growing
up as Muslims we're going to hell you
can stop
you can stop can you talk to someone
maybe but here's the thing if I don't
believe in hell then you can also not
you know what I mean like well it's cool
like I'm fine if you believe in in God
and you believe in hell as well right
yeah you you can't you need them
right for us at least yeah
is in um in Islam like I know in
Christianity you can like live your life
like an absolute demon
but as long as you accept Jesus in the
last moment you get to go to heaven is
there something like that in Islam hell
no we got we got we got the hardest now
we could some sometimes people will say
like you could uh make up stuff in hell
like spend a certain amount of time in
hell then go to oh
so you are incentivized to
even if you've been up it's like
yeah I'm gonna go to hell but if I'm
good from now on I might go to hell for
less time yeah
some Christians believe in stuff like
that too I think
it's mostly there's a a lot of different
uh variations on on the theme and
honestly what you said uh though that
may be true for some denominations the
the whole as long as you accept Jesus
you go to heaven that isn't the case for
all Christians the more critical thing
is that you genuinely feel remorse and
repent for the evil things that you yeah
right I feel remorse right as opposed to
just like oh no but I see but that's
they'll say and you're not sincere it
doesn't work no I believe them but what
if you're like
you're like listen I'm a Christian I
believe it all but
I'm gonna I gotta do some really
up things but at the end of the day you
know when it's time to to uh
do the big sleep I'm gonna say you know
hey I'm back and I'm with you it seems
like a loophole
do you pray Ethan
no no he's an atheist
do you pray Zach I do pray I pray every
night before bed do you pray is there a
difference between Jewish prayer and I
think I just pray to
um just some type of higher being
anything whatever and what do you or can
I ask what you pray for yeah just like
you know all my blessings in life be
grateful for that and I pray for the
wants I pray for the uh
sure
do you need this very nice I need to be
in your prayers brother
I'll pray for you tonight bro
because I'll know if you're not if I'm
not in your prayers I'll know
um
I think a lot of religion has to do with
what's the word
superstition
it's almost like an OCD thing where it's
like you feel compelled to do something
or else something bad is going to happen
but we do that illogically like if you
have OCD you'd be like I got to do the
light switch this many times or
something bad is going to happen and so
like
it's like a main line into our psyche or
whatever the whatever the we've got
this reason for soup um Superstition
it's just a main line into that I'm the
poster boy then
yes some would argue that um religion is
was created to incite fear oh that's for
sure well right I think there's two yeah
religion is definitely the oldest weapon
you know Hollis do you get someone to do
something for nothing but also at the
same time it gives people guidance too
you know my my dad's family for example
came over from Lebanon with no father in
the picture and there was 12 kids and
they were very poor and I think they
they all became successful to a degree
because of the religious values that
they got and they stayed out of trouble
even though they grew up in a rough
neighborhood because they were so afraid
of uh you know going to hell yeah I
think when it's used properly religion
is a beautiful thing I think it's really
disappointing that so many people have
used it as a weapon
I think it was used as a um distraction
and I feel it still is in a way
I mean I don't think that you can have
religion where it's not abused because
people
they use it
uh to justify doing anything they want
at the end of the day uh do you have
good practitioners and and uh bad
practitioners and you know as long as
God's on their side they can do whatever
the they want
you know
but in some cases like you said a b then
you know when you're good people and
you're using religion in a a good faith
way then then you're gonna get good
things out of it
kind of gives us what we want from it
and people can that's the thing you got
the Bible has been read a bajillion
times because
people want to just they want to find a
way to justify what they want to do and
so you just keep looking you're like
okay this line is going to justify what
I want to do
let's do it
God did God did
but I don't know
you know what I mean
the do I know
in it
that being said most of my friends my
age they're all like massive ups
because they think they're going to hell
anyway so they're like it let's
have a good time okay so that's a real
yeah wow
do they really believe in hell then yes
absolutely really
that seems like a poor decision and that
that seems yeah that seems like a really
eternity of Torment but in exchange
yeah but it's not just something to make
it turn off though I mean it's something
that's like ingrained in us even like no
matter how unlogical it sounds or feels
it's like it's
yeah I'm sorry go ahead so sorry when
that's the narrative like the first
narrative that you hear as a kid you
take it as truth so like I had to
unlearn all of the that or like I
had to
revisit it as myself with my own mind as
opposed to being told as a child that
like this is true this is truth
it's like it's a tough thing to do and
to realize that you have to do it
amen
my grandma is like I'm very close to my
grandma my mom's side but she's
Christian my whole mom's side of the
family is Christian and like as a kid I
was like that's my biggest fear is like
my grandma's gonna go to hell and I used
to like ask like some of my religious
aunts like what's gonna happen oh yeah
she's gonna burn I'm like oh did
you ever wonder like maybe they're right
maybe the Christians have their answer
uh yeah there were times where I uh I
questioned which team I was joining you
know it's like well maybe you're the one
going to hell and Jesus's version of of
reality
because Jesus is the goat
and and
he's the version 1.3 he's the newest
update no no we're the newest update
that's why you are yeah no sorry oh so
you this is actually Obsolete and
most and then you got it brother I'm
covering all my bases yeah you wanna you
wanna know what's stuck in purgatory is
our Panera
literally
screw dude I want my soup and it's in
God's waiting room right now God's
holding our soup
yo where's our soup does it say eta it
says 455 and the driver 455 I gotta go
home
it's five o'clock right the same way
you're talking about and now has how the
driver was he was really upset and he
was blaming it on the restaurant dude
Panera Bread bro and to be fair I
placed a separate order for Ila to the
house and it took just as long she got
hurt not long ago what yeah I feel bad
for the driver because how long has he
spent on this dumbass order one order
yeah
that sucks what did we tip him Lena let
me check
foreign
man I was here I was ready to endorse
Panera Bread but this is
this is a Panera disaster
a soup zoster
you know Esther you know while we're
talking about religion and about uh
ubereats I have some confessions to make
uh oh
I went to check last week because I made
the order because Lena wasn't here and I
wanted to make sure I didn't charge my
card and it didn't thankfully
uh but then I noticed that the work card
was charged for the previous order I was
like oh that's strange and I looked at
the one before that
and before I knew it I was like a three
weeks in and I think I had about 800 on
the work card of personal ubereats
yeah if only you cared about the work
card being charged as much as your
personal card
you would have caught it a long time ago
and I was freaking out I was like well
at first I'm like oh my God it was like
a year of this how long has it been but
I found out that it was because I got a
new card at the end of last month that
it will for every reason when my old car
didn't work is switched to the work card
but this happens I guess pretty often
because they have a feature where if
it's in within 30 days you could swap
the card that is pretty sweet I've never
heard of that
yeah how do they do but you said you put
like 800 yeah it was like 800 roughly
over A month's period so let's see 800
divided by 30. what's your daily average
26.
it's not bad yeah we don't get it every
day and then like Lena will pay for it
sometimes
right she has a different card you'll
pay for it sometimes
right there you go nice I got you you'll
be like I'm sure Ethan would be fine
with this I've worked really hard this
week
wait what's his tip Lena it's 35. oh we
tipped him 35. it's 20 of our order yeah
that's a good tip that's a pretty good
tip that's a good tip yeah okay
you can bump at the 40. make it 40.
round it up wow okay round it up
and Panera wasted a lot of time on this
Panera dude
I wanted to love you and there's no way
the food's gonna be good if it took this
long to get here
it wasn't on the ride that took so long
was the restaurant itself isn't it isn't
it like a fast food yeah basically yeah
like they're all it's like easy I
wonder if they have like a
deal with a specific Courier or
something because
I've never had trouble with them
I you know what I've learned they're all
I don't want to believe that Panera is
bad the Panera is evil
the Nara needs to find God
that's right repent
I found all these delivery services I
think is owned by the same company
because all I use Postmates when I order
on Postmates it's Uber Eats delivers
then it's Postmates another time and
then another time it's like it's door
Dash
doordash is a different company but
Postmates and ubereats are the same
thing okay yeah I'm all I'm I like
doordash the most I use doordash two the
most Dasher it's the same no I feel
like it's quicker it's also cheaper
there's no there's no they don't stop
they don't like they do one delivery
rather than multiple also I subscribe to
their thing and it's like 12 bucks a
month and they take away all the fees
it's like I do that on Postman it saves
three bucks to every order
it's very nice yeah I have that on post
match
um
dude
man well maybe now you can end
up enjoying it with ELO then
yeah looking on the bright side it can
sit for another hour on the way home
I'm excited for my chilled tomato sauce
dude how long is it away now
stop with the tomatoes please keep
asking all right
I gotta go with my Panera that bread
gonna be bummer I'm gonna take my Panera
to go I'll do a taste test here so the
people can find out
jadian turned to God so it seems real
though
which is an interesting development
I mean if my soul was on the line if I
was faced with eternal Hellfire then I
do it too you know what I mean there you
go
scary
eternity is a long time that's a long
time bro you know
god dude you like my theory that he's
sticking it to rumble or no
I doesn't make sense I completely agree
with you at first before I watched the
the videos that's what I was thinking
but after seeing it I think that he's
legit
so Ah that's really interesting I guess
we'll follow along man
you know dude it's a shame that he feels
like this is the only way you can be a
good person without I don't know that's
kind of my thought process can be oh
yeah 100 I've learned that human life
like some of the worst people are the
most religious and then you know it
don't matter people yeah
uh let's watch I I wanted to give the
rectangular music video premiere it's
dues and I watch it with Oliver who did
not take it seriously
and so I want to now you know Sean was
was gracious enough to send this to us
so I want to actually watch this music
video now and give it you know
110 years the premiere that it blocked
in yeah yeah yeah okay so here it is he
said he spent a ton of money on it
here it is
it starts with a rectangle perfect
on brand
[Music]
and you are a circle I am rectangular
why would you try to brush your teeth if
your head was in a box
like you know your head's in a box you
would you what did you do the morning
before
well I think the head is
his head I think that's his head dude oh
that's his right but then so what so
what I'm gonna brush the box kind of
cringe dude no the teeth in the Box
he's gonna put it under the box yeah
let's see what he does
[Music]
triangle
yo did he destroy triangle that's not
even in the equation we have circles and
we have rectangles I've always wondered
what his thoughts on triangles were
though because I always thought that was
very conspicuous the triangle is the
simplest uh platonic shape other than a
circle right
that yeah three lines yeah and two lines
you got nothing three you got a shape
strongest shape right and it's the
strongest triangles are very important
yeah well he doesn't seem to like them
the Father the Son and the Holy Ghost
here he's doing one and he does not like
it
more triangles
[Music]
the promise
I kind of wished it would be like just
something so wildlike you remember the
video for Jeremy
uh from Pearl Jam
the kid like brings the gun into school
and kills himself in front of the class
not the music video dude yeah
sure hear me from Pearl Jam is one of
the craziest music videos ever damn
yeah so that was like damn you know what
I mean like
give me a Twist but we'll see maybe
there's a Twist oh damn yeah it's age
restricted the music video on YouTube
that was on MTV
I watched that when I was like
eight I didn't even understand what
happened right
they they show blood splashing on their
face and stuff sick it was kind of an
interesting Insight too because it was
before the age of mass shooting
the idea of bringing a gun to school was
not one that was part of the cultural
they were innovatized
interesting
[Music]
that's what you look like is that a good
one or not I am rectangular that was
okay
he's not happy that he's rectangular
[Music]
yo guys this is me right they can see
that
right the drawing wouldn't be helpful
because they can see right
his head is square a rectangular
actually
this guy's a hentai shirt what the
hentai
Hennessy and Thai Hennessy I don't know
what that is
shout out
[Music]
I thought he was forcing her out of the
chair
look at this
I mean to be fair you were coming in a
little ahead and you're wearing it right
like putting the arm around her back
before you know you say anything that's
that's
I don't blame her for running
[Music]
[Applause]
bro
[Music]
head cutie
she's happy no no she is oh she was sad
before yeah okay just found a rectangle
she found a rectangle it's a filler hole
dude this is a really nice
story you could interpret a lot of ways
like if you think back like with the
Columbine kids like they found each
other they're so different but they
found each other and you could say that
like you know G Lane Maxwell and and F
stream it's like how do these people
find each other where they're both like
so depraved and that's
fascinating and that's what this music
video is yeah right you know what I mean
yeah yeah yeah do you ever wonder that
like how did y'all Broach this subject
like you there's two pedo guys who are
doing it it's like how do you how did
you broach the subject with him they're
two squares man living in a circle world
the Columbine shooters were like big
fans of uh Natural Born Killers and same
storyline they found each other both
Killers I think they're actually
interesting usually on fourshan and
stuff like that yeah
now right now yeah Panera so back then
man
it was like so uh
been thinking about the
killing everyone at school
to like duh yeah yeah I mean you
know
it's dark it's a dark video yeah it's a
really sad dark video I'm sure Sean's
loving that what is my analysis not
right on I mean that's different if
you're just like a little different
you're going to fit in somewhere to be
like that different you need to be like
pathological
you know what I mean like one a one in a
million you'll find them easy because of
the boxes the Box shapes I think my
analysis is that this is just a day this
is like his whole life in a day and he's
looking looking and don't give up
because one day you'll turn a corner and
you'll find someone that fits you but
that's what I mean he's been looking his
whole life and he never found someone
like him like he's like but he
did he's got to be like really yeah
really unique that's true that's like
really really unique
[Music]
I'm not commenting about anything Sean's
implying this is just my artist you know
it's just a reflection of ourselves and
I'm not even saying that's what it means
it's just one interpretation
right
oh I I'm here
thank you give me the soup well we have
to review it
it is touching we gotta go it's a
beautiful love story and they're both
[Music]
yeah that's nice
that's nice
that was nice
wow they found each other
right well clearly it's not a it's not a
parable for
Columbine because it was a man and a
woman falling in love
so we can discount that
you were on to something I thought so
something something powerful to say the
least
you know
soup two all right the food is here
let's give it a taste stuff so I can
leave Panera dude
Panera more like camberia
oh got him yeah dude yeah
oh my God
you like that Dan don't you it's great
oh it was so good
I agree thanks for for thanks for
acknowledging
all right
here we go whoa yeah we got drinks I
forgot oh that's so yummy thank you
okay all right that wasn't gonna look
bad
my orange blast
it drinks a little weird but it's diet
so I can't really Judge Too Much
this this Greek looks good you know
that's what I like to see in a Greek
salad
feta okay
this tastes like purple onions tastes
like Fanta without bubbles thank you
oh God it's so little soup
hold on the bread Bowl's not that big
I mean I've seen bigger bread bowls no
so here's the bread bowl
okay
we want some bread
you like bread I don't know
usually he doesn't eat bread
's good you don't like it
perfect
nice bro tell me how is it
how much was that low probably like 10
bucks how much wait this isn't my soup
what the
this is my soup
the bread's good though
here's my dude nice hearty sourdough
Cheers Cheers
oh it's sourdough yeah
a toast to you toast cheers toast to you
toasting good homo that's good
um toasting
I got it no I got where you're all good
I get it
I thought this would be lunch but now
it's dinner yeah yeah I'm gonna have to
bring this home there's no way I might
have time to eat this
bread is good though nice you know
good bread
let me see how's your bread down
you're making progress on that hmm
that's that's that's all like medieval
peasants used to get down at dinner girl
Panda hand me the loaf
my goodness thank you uh this I don't
know whose soup this is who got the
broccoli cheddar and pasta
there's pasta in it
me no I got the
Lena didn't I get the cream of chicken
you did but they didn't have it oh and I
said it in the in the chat but I don't
know if you saw it Oh I did order that
one for you at your house though
yeah oh why does it have an air all over
the place
oh it does I don't know that's weird
super weird wait so you actually do have
to take all the bread off it's pre-cut
well it's cobbed but it's still all the
bread in there oh it looks like they
yours up
I just took the lid off this place you
break all that bread up and you put it
in your soup
no you put the soup inside of it yeah
yeah and then yeah I gotta like dig it
out with my hands now yeah oh that's
that's kind of on the soup is so not
yeah warm it sucks bro you could
use a utensil I guess why is there pasta
in my broccoli cheddar
that goes right in there though
it's not bad
just confused by them
it's like a mac and cheese soup
good though
bye I'm gonna have to wait I'm just
gonna here's what I'm gonna do for now
look at that
the go I take mine to go please
good
age three yeah so what do you think of
the price now that you saw the portion
um I think it's yeah
I think it's about
fairly priced yeah me too maybe I see
what you're saying maybe a little
expensive
is there the pizza
this is sick though
like I'm building my own you're
with the soup did we get a pizza Lena I
like the green turtle I didn't get an
order for pizza
you didn't hear that no no I'm sorry you
guys were saying it I I took the orders
from chat
everything that was in chat damn
no that's not your fault
even what you want to wrap it up
please
Dan is begging me to end the show
Wednesdays Wednesdays I always have to
uh prep
to be totally ready by the end of the
night because we do leftovers first
thing in the morning so that's why I'm
also eager again that's higher on
Wednesdays that's true
that is true Dan
just keeps putting it up all right I
mean I got nothing else to say all right
yesterday it took a long time it
did these guys tomorrow for golf lovers
Friday's gonna be the big members Drive
password